all right and we are live the last word
with lord cognito ibantas thai guy
travis not on thursday that special
edition
friday morning destiny campfire got a
special guest before we get into that
hey how are we doing sir
oh ben
um sleeping less and less i think every
day leading into
this big weekend of hopefully not a 24
hour if the skill is there
but uh as long as it hopefully takes to
put in this weekend so
nothing but destiny lots of videos lots
of um
a little bit of caffeine here and there
you know just whatever it takes to get
through and getting ready for this thing
how about uh how about you travis i know
you are
you are less thrilled to be awake this
morning but you've got good reason so
what how are you doing sir i am just got
back from a business trip and uh my
flight got delayed so i got in at 1 and
it's 5 30 right now where i'm at so
yeah i'm well i'm living on fumes but
i've been playing a lot of destiny my
review in progress is live on ign.com
and yeah looking forward to uh get that
thing
uh
done once i've completed the raid and
any other ending in game content that
comes out so i haven't been playing as
much destiny because i got to 1550
assume that that would be high enough
and now i've just been playing a
crapload of eldon ring which i'm
absolutely loving i'm jealous of that
but yeah
it's been a good it's gonna be an
awesome couple weeks for games i i
completely even forgot about uh horizon
at this point just because there's so
many other things i feel bad for that
game again
i do but on the other hand i don't know
you know
i'm living my best life that studio is
cursed man every time they put something
out they just like hey we're gonna put
out our game and then two days later a
groundbreaking game in the same exact
genre launches and it's like damn yeah
and it does make it look bad by
comparison i really can't go back to
horizon after playing eleanor because
it's just so that's the order i should
play them okay good to know probably man
honestly although although i know you
won't you lose
i love souls too much like souls
i'll give because i played horizon one
like 50 hours straight in a week just to
like knock it out so i played that
somewhat fresh recently so the farther
away horizon gets from that probably the
better it's going to be for me so it's
not quite overdone yeah they're very
similar games so i would space them out
to be honest
well
before we get going kyle what about you
sir what have you been up to grinding
bro you know
look we got we got my boy chris reagan
here but i told maddie i was like we do
defining duke if you ask me what we're
playing for three to four weeks it's
gonna be the same thing
so he was like oh i already see what you
do i was like the grind man the grind
i'm getting rey ready getting the bells
going shout out to the um to the hustle
that got patched though shout out to the
hustler with the two chests do y'all
y'all
just yeah i was out there on the two
chests in the throne world doing my
thing so i got what i needed there but
um yeah man it's just been non-stop and
like you he's just not been good sleep
i've been averaging like three or four
bro it's it's crazy but yo you know you
know what we do but enough about me we
got a special guest we gotta bring in
even tony tell us about this guess we
got all right let's do it how we do chat
hopefully you guys are ready welcome to
the last word episode number 187
palms are sweaty knees are weak and
mom's spaghetti is ready for the raid
race tomorrow many will be squaring off
with the valve of the disciple
so spend time with your families today
you will not see them for the remainder
of the weekend
on this hallowed raid eve we will try to
decipher the sacred symbols of the
youtube algorithm oh wait our guest
already did that with his own song
seriously a man of many talents joins us
this morning at the campfire first off a
true talent in the gaming world
and known by the sci-fi weapon in his
name who has both green and blue blood
in his veins the talent reaches far
beyond gaming though this man's vocal
cords have likely graced your ears with
a parody song that will always be well
written and researched topical and funny
yet brings the state of the world to a
head that makes you question many things
about life a true gem that will bring a
smile to your face with this comedy or
poke the bear of the internet just to
see how it reacts so let's welcome but
not keep forever because you know he
didn't eat before the show a man who
thinks the internet is just a little too
horny finds little things in life like
the fact that spyro exists again and
knows there ain't no rest for the
triggered the host of the snark take
sacred symbols and owner of some of the
best damn content on youtube the one the
only chris reagan how are you doing this
morning sir jesus what you got right
here put your goddamn hands together
how do you even respond to that i mean
thanks for having me on i'm excited to
talk about destiny because i'd never get
to that's right
we'll see we wrapped everything else up
in a nice little bow
yeah you did that was [ __ ] awesome
god damn
yeah man long overdue man glad glad you
could make it i don't mean you were
chopping it up at the event i was like
yo i got to get you on i said we do what
we're doing the tour he goes i got to
get you
last word we got to get your iop
definitely around witch queen and i'm
glad it it definitely worked out
schedule wise and then we got trav in
the building so it all worked out yeah
so what's been going on like have you
been in the grind like what's been going
on with you yeah man so i i i'm not
gonna lie i fell off at destiny a little
bit the last not because it was a bad
season just because there was so much to
play like so much stuff that i had to
catch up on i wanted to get on i want to
i wanted to catch up on some of the
titles that i missed from like years ago
like i got into pray like super recently
out of nowhere and that was fantastic
good though yeah it's amazing i'm not
done with it but like like because again
something else came up and like
it's a busy [ __ ] life but this this
last month in particular with games has
been
crazy but i've been excited for the
witch queen ever since i heard about it
and i know me and you cog we're talking
about it at the live event literally
when we were talking was like oh we got
to do a show and witch
queen launches
because it looks awesome just the
premise of hive guardians in the first
place and
i don't know i've been all over
this expansion i've been all over elden
ring i've been dabbling in sifu and
horizon on my off time and i've been
sleeping about two hours a day yeah uh i
it's
it's a it's a lot but
it's been a good month because all of
these titles have been fantastic uh and
it's just
mean i know best campaign
yeah in destiny
history by a long
long long long shot i know there's a lot
of opinions out there about taking king
and and forsaken and i liked taken king
i thought taken king was good
i thought forsaken was enjoyable
but this is honestly one of the first
times story-wise
and campaign-wise that i felt
that bungie has been
close to where they were during the halo
days i even think it it compares to a
lot of their that's big from you yeah
you know for real like i i genuinely
like is this better than combat evolved
i think so
is this but is this interesting is this
is this better than reach you could make
a good case
i agree is this better than your game of
all time no is this three [ __ ]
let's calm down
but man i'm just so impressed by this by
this expansion there are some quirks
obviously it's a live service game i
think i think crafting is in a bit of a
weird spot yeah we'll get to that and
i'm sure we'll get into all that stuff
but overall man i i've been loving this
expansion top to bottom pvp aside
yeah i totally agree with your comments
on the campaign because i was talking to
somebody about how
the destiny campaigns are kind of graded
on a curve of the fact that you know
destiny's story has never been good and
so
you get a forsaken and a taken king and
you're like oh this is really good
for destiny right
but big asterisks but but but the witch
queen is the first campaign that is
genuinely actively good on its own like
separate from the destiny kind of
asterisk it's like it's actually a
a deeply good campaign so i i agree with
you there i don't know i don't know if
it's as good as combat evolved uh but
you know pretty damn good so
yeah
i don't know i i've just been super
super impressed by it and just the
glaive and and all of all the we'll
we'll get into it there's a lot to talk
about but
no doubt yeah
and i don't know how are you guys
feeling about it overall
e oh we probably raved a lot last time
but yeah i mean for destiny campaigns i
don't it yeah i'm with you guys it
doesn't compare it after i mean i played
through the entire thing three times
solo kind of going through four
different videos and stuff that i did so
i got to experience that one and then i
did jump in with that three-person um
finale fight which i won't really quite
say too much but
um
yeah just the fact that they scaled the
difficulty it's still approachable by
one but you've got kind of a good
challenge for three
more cutscenes than i think we've ever
had before the voice acting by debra
wilson is
just stellar all the way through this
entire thing just loving her character
and glad to see we get more and more as
the weeks progress like this week we got
more story we got more two truths and
two lies like things like that continue
to build on top of what we got going on
in the season
yeah season of the risen is running
right alongside it we're trying to
figure out what's going on with the
loose and hive
you know we got
quite a deep deep cut this week
which was
yeah so that's probably the most we've
ever seen out of our man from the iron
banner so it's been
it's been the story machine firing on
basically all cylinders without question
leading into witch queen and then now
just like delivering on just kind of the
hope i had for the story and then you
turn around and you have to do pinnacles
in gambit
and then you go look at the crucible
menu and then you have to turn around
and just kind of like you have to check
and be like
this stuff's really cool
but it's not all done yet it's like
there's there's some more work to do
it's like we have a road map for pvp we
know that
gambit got changed to where it's longer
but then people are saying if you like
get a couple invasion kills you start
the whole thing over for the there's
there's some bumps in the road but
overall i would say same thing we'll get
into the details on crafting because i
really want to kind of pick your brings
on that one because
that's what i've been spending a lot of
time in um
overall just in a really good spot for
the game right now i'm just happy to see
that it's a nice time to be excited for
destiny and for the first time i would
say story-wise especially as travis said
there's much less of a caveat that you
have to put on there for story you don't
need to but there is a little bit for
those couple other segments of the game
that were aren't a hundred percent yeah
i think i think that legendary mode is
like it's like i cuz i soloed it
legendary and i was i was getting but i
was getting tilted man
that is
no joke
it's genuinely challenging i tried there
was this one point in in the final boss
where i was like it took me ages to get
her down to like the point where she was
summoning those uh those guardians the
the fire team
and i got two of them and and the wizard
was like the the the ark wizard was like
[ __ ] me up and i was like oh man and
i hid behind one of the back uh
one of the back towers
and all of a sudden
because i was just like it was the only
way to stay safe from those supers it's
insane and then i just i hear silence i
was like
what's going on did a peek wizard fell
off the map
and you have to and you have to finish
and you have to finish the game
so like so like i was like oh mike i was
screaming because i was like you gotta
be kidding me i spent so many hours on
this one fight and now i can't finish it
and i did it and that happened twice by
the way so it's just like the game is
just like it doesn't yeah the game does
not want you to cheese it i was cheesing
it in fairness i was like outside i was
being the cheese it was a bit of a [ __ ]
the cheese was too raunchy that morning
so yeah yeah
[Laughter]
but that aside been ah
so good so good so good yeah man i'm
with y'all like the campaign you know
i've already raved ranted and raved
about how much i love the legendary
difficulty the scaling based on the fire
team the rewards thank god they're
giving me upgrade modules the light
level the path to
decent you know to the soft cap i felt
was such an underrated thing
that you know just straight past it
yeah like you know what i mean it wasn't
even a thing i was like oh that's gone
yeah and it's so cool that if you do the
campaign you can do that right like i
just thought that like shout out to them
for that but for me now it's just about
the minutia of the builds and void 3.0
and and now i'm like yo these weapons
are really
good like i was messing with um what is
this there was it was a season of the
risen the uh the the the helm stuff well
did y'all get that pulse did you get
that kinetic uh fast fire the kinetic
yeah i think it's like a five bro it's
crazy they got a wave frame launcher
that's solar that's crazy you could do
some um signal frame launcher that's all
three
yeah yeah no i know i got to get going
on that i'm saving that for today
because i'm saving all the exotic quests
for the last minute so i get them at the
highest possible light prior to raid
that was like my strategy and then do
everything else but i just been in yeah
it's been in a build mode and obviously
everything has been in prep for the raid
we'll i know we'll talk about it and
stuff like that but i just want to be in
a situation where okay boom
if they need obviously going at some
point they're going to need a well i
know that but i want to actually think
about yo i might bring stasis in there
hey i might bring void 3.0 i just want
to be varied because i don't know how
the encounters are going to go so i'm
just kind of having everything set up
but yeah i've been loving it man i just
can't stop playing it's bad it's messing
up my sleep schedule
that's what i know is good when i just i
just keep thinking about getting back on
and then one more thing turns into four
to five hours and i'm like god damn i
get two out of sleep again but anyway
that's with me what a [ __ ] trap
yeah um i i totally agree on the
campaign actually our uh our reviewer
for eldon ring mitchell saltzman he's a
good friend of mine uh he he was saying
that the he didn't get to play the
destiny 2 campaign until well after
eldon ring was out because he was busy
with the review uh but he said that a
lot of the sections on the legendary
campaign were harder than the elden ring
he was just like this is straight up
like super difficult and that was so
that was so good to see because i think
people don't really understand until
they go into it but like in my mind
that's the way that campaign was meant
to be played like on the hard difficulty
because it just changes it like raises
the stakes it makes you feel like you're
actually fighting someone who
is a threat rather than somebody just
like steamroll like we have been doing
for every year so it's so important you
do get that satisfaction too it's like a
very similar level of satisfaction and i
agree man i've been playing
elden ring a lot like i streamed i
streamed it for 13 hours the other day
and it was that's
when i do that first that's probably how
that's going to go
it's
and and i got to tell you man like i was
i was having a hard time with some of
the elden ring bosses sure but
i was not getting nearly as tilted as i
was in some of these some of these
exchanges with these these these bosses
and these in these encounters and these
great like these puzzle rooms yeah
require you to really like
think a little bit and it's like this is
kind of cool like this is very very new
for destiny and and uh i was gonna say
like hard
do you think that destiny has been
sandbagging
so long that when they finally present a
campaign that's actually difficult we're
like oh i can just run through can i get
i'm not used because you're like el
dorado i'm used to getting my ass kicked
i'm used to dying a lot i know i'm gonna
walk up to a guy get one shot multiple
times
you don't expect that in destiny and
then all of a sudden we walk into the
legendary campaign and there's this
guardian that throws a void shield at
you and he just takes your head clean
off and you get to start over
it's just one of those things i did not
expect and i think yeah they presented
that in a really really cool way
yeah i thought that that was a
realization for me like the fact
narratively that they stole the light
right that's one thing but to actually
fight hive guards and like chris was
saying the the mechanic of having to
finish the ghost literally changes
things because now you have to get out
of your safe haven right and go out
there in the mix especially if they're
around other enemies so that's the first
part but the second part i remember it
really hit me when
you know they use their super and you
get one hit
killed
like like you've been doing to the
enemies all these years and i'm like yo
and i kind of laughed i'm like yo that
it's kind of right though like it makes
sense and it just it added a different
you know level to it a different layer
to it i really enjoyed it
yeah
well you know the rest of my opinions
about the which cream campaign you can
read on ign it's like 3000 words or
something but
i i will say like the only thing that uh
that that really bothers me about the
campaign so far is the stuff that isn't
there right to easepoint we talked a lot
about how gambit and crucible oh
basically just been left rotting on the
vine and it's it's kind of bizarre how
how much they have as well i think we
just lost he's gone he's in the bees in
the bushes he's back
good i think he just lost all of us
because he left so well
yeah
yeah stream's still going stream's going
but we just got to get the pictures back
up you're good to go
yes
i've moved up
yeah all right we should be back
hopefully everybody can hear you
i gotta
this feel like a minor version i'm just
joking
yeah it's like it seems a little funky
this morning you changed it over
uh
i will do that again but
give it a shot
yeah nothing new yeah no sadly not but
yeah sorry everybody uh if you guys saw
a video hiccup there in the world
i have no idea what that's gonna come
through on the audio end but that's
it's literally like restarting discord
over and over and over
um
that's not good that's not good okay let
me close discord yeah close it everybody
breathe for half a second they'll try
and just restart it oh this is
what a wonderful morning chris i'm sorry
we we run a good ship here
don't judge us
it's a discord feature it's not a bug
it's a feature of discord
a feature
yeah it's a feature though
i never asked you this because like in
general like
what was for you like the beginning when
you kind of like
fell in love with destiny when you were
like okay
this is the game for me
oh man i don't know man i think i i was
all on board from the second i heard
bungie was working on something else you
know like i've been a huge bungee guy
like i loved the original halo trilogy i
loved uh reach and odst odst in
particular i just have like a massive
soft spot for um just that soundtrack
and everything about it and when i heard
that they were doing some like weird mmo
[ __ ] i was like that's awesome and i
remember they
for e3 they showed uh dude i'm still
rocking thunderlord like i still have
that in my in my heavy slot and it will
always be there because i remember that
just that first
e3 where they showed you you coming into
old russia through the wall and fighting
that spider tank and and and it was just
uh
i remember being so excited and enamored
by just the the aesthetic and the and
the sound design and just the music and
everything about it and obviously it
came out and it was ah
you know it was fine
but then vault of glass came out and i
was like okay
this is
this is not what i wanted but this is
incredible
and this is really cool and there's
something here that i think uh
has a lot of potential and i you know i
i
i stuck with it for varying degrees like
i waved in and out to kind of check some
other games out and
eventually
i just kind of landed in a spot where
wow i think i'm i think this game might
be one of my favorites of all time
whereas i think before i was just sort
of impressed by how different it was in
comparison to other titles that i had
played
and uh i think it was at some i think
probably forsaken
is when i is when i kind of got into it
and like when they added bows
and i was just like
they made a first person bow in a in a
game with pvp that feels awesome
and i don't know how you do that
it's something that i feel like only
bungie can do like i don't know man i've
played i played uh so many fps's and i
think call of duty has some games where
they have bows and it's just like it
doesn't feel right it just feels weird
and the bows just felt so good and
forsaken i was like what are they doing
yeah they're on crack over there
yeah uh i was just i've been in and out
ever since it's a live service game so
it kind of you know it's it's
it's one of those things but i think
once the seasonal model kicked in
once once the seasonal model kicked in
and it was like narratively satisfying
so within like the last year or two i
think it really became something that
like okay
this is something i'm going to
consistently pay attention to and not
just kind of jump in
for a month and then leave for a couple
months and then come back it's something
that i'm going to consistently stick
with
so yeah enough fair enough a little
traffic crosses your fingers
don't breathe or look at it wrong just
we might be good we don't make him mad
but we'll see
it's the weirdest thing i've never seen
discord
just literally reboot itself like
multiple times in a row that's never
maybe no yeah could be update could be
yeah
if you open task manager sometimes
there's multiple versions of this open
once it's the same thing happens with
obs where like
my obs will freak the [ __ ] out and then
i'll check my task manager it's like you
have 14 obs windows open it's like how
the
what where yeah i killed them i killed
them all i saw those when uh cogs had it
in chat so that's hopefully it
goodness look at that dude have you
tried turning it off and turn it on
again it worked
good for you yeah you know let's try
that one don't do it like that
i didn't pour the water in there at
least so that's good
not as good technology is so [ __ ]
stupid i i just
i it's just you do you don't do anything
different you leave everything exactly
as it is and then somehow it's just
infinitely more ruined than it was the
day before when nothing changes it's
it's
what a finicky [ __ ] yep very finicky
that's what that's my biggest pet peeve
coming back to
settings that have changed based on an
update or just any type of little thing
that throws you off so i know the
feeling was gonna say i want to set up a
tribe for the because the reason why i
wanted to do this on this show because i
gotta get traffic is uh some pvp love
man i know chris you get your pvp oh i
wanted to know how you feel about the
state of memory are you a trials guy and
you know just in general i need traffic
to engage
oh man pvp has been in a rush it's
happening
for a long time to the point where like
i remember when destiny destiny 2 was
like my only game
and
this just died i'm playing it because i
like i like the pve game i like the
narrative that's happening and i'm
already here i might as well do this is
gonna be the worst
you're going to enjoy it on some level
but at the same time
i think we're at a point now similar to
where destiny 1 was in years
where
not as far as content but as far as the
complexity of like what's going on why
are there so many like everything feels
so those pages are going out like out of
this world where it's like you're just
walking and then suddenly you're dead
and you don't know how much there's a
million possibilities this is why that
might be the case there's so many
different builds it's a little it's a
bit overwhelming as that goes but even
if that weren't the problem
the problem that remains consistently is
there's just no jesus new content at all
there's no new game mode there's no new
there's no new maps and it's like how
have we gone what two plus years maybe
even three i'm not down i'm not even
sure how long it's been since we've
gotten a new map we've gotten one nap in
two years
it's insane and we've lost 11 maps in
that time yeah and you know what what's
what's really strange this about this
for me is
there are a lot of maps
from d1 that they could bring over that
have not been in the game yet
specifically those big team maps when it
when the game was like 6v6 and you could
summon sparrows in multiplayer why not
bring those over it's not new but it's
something different for d2 at least yeah
and those maps i actually really loved
those maps like the the moon map that
was in the beta for d1
and there was this mars one that i
remember really liking and there's a
bunch of stuff from d1 that they could
pour it over with you know minimal work
um it's the easy way out but it does
solve
at least some part of the problem i'm
not saying you got to go and make
perfectly new crafted play spaces but
give us something new and even as simple
as something that d1 used to do where
they had these game modes like rift
where it was capture the flag or or um
even the something as simple as the
sparrow racing league which was like a
weird
like i
i thought that was so cool but i'm a
racing guy like i kind of like those
kart racers and the fact that destiny
had anything even remotely like that i
thought was really really cool and
interesting because what other fps game
has a game mode like that that you could
participate in competitive multiplayer
no none
and i get that that would be hard
because there's a whole bunch of you
know there's sparrows and and
there's not exactly a robust speed
system there that you could really
take advantage of
but dude it's something it's something
different it's something casual at least
and whereas right now everything feels
like a
a different version of the same
oh uh it just feels like a different
version of team slayer you know that's
what it feels like it's just like here's
eight different versions of team slayer
on the same maps you've been playing on
for
48 years and uh it just gets a little
exhausting and just the fact that
it feels like
they're not paying much attention to it
is is just
you know it's it's a little
disappointing
yeah
it's like
i talk about this all the time because
i'm like a die-hard pvp main and it it's
uh
it's crazy that that they used to have
objective modes and they took them out
of the game and haven't added them
yeah you know capture the flag man i
played so much of that game mode when it
was out in uh in d1 and they haven't
added it back which is crazy to me
because we're now in a place where
destiny's uh movement finally feels
really good because they struggled with
that for a really long time and
especially with uh
with the geometry how you'd always you
know d1 my catchphrase was practically
what am i stuck on like in destiny i was
just like you know how you always really
get stuck on the environment in that
game and you still do in destiny 2 not
as much but um yeah it's crazy to me
they still haven't added that so the the
pvp world it almost feels like
they weren't having too much success
there so they just re-prioritized in pve
and now you see the success they're
having the pvp world makes me wonder if
they're even really trying to make
destiny a pvp game again especially with
this new project they're working on that
apparently is a pvp only game or at
least yeah yeah it matters right so
matter yeah yeah i
i think they're definitely trying to
maybe put some effort into that to kind
of get back into the proper competitive
uh pvp space because it's a place where
they haven't been in a long time i mean
i mean trials and and things and iron
banner that's competitive within the
world of destiny but it's not proper
competitive pvp it's not even talk to
him you know trav loves that
i mean it's
i mean
you can't really be competitive when you
have 9 000 weapons in your sandbox yeah
yeah exactly it's it's it's not possible
it's too the the variations are too high
and it just becomes a a logistical
nightmare to balance for you you can't
you can't have something
truly competitive at that level like you
can have competitive within the context
of the game like i love
trials and i i mean it's as as
furious as it makes me
sometimes
uh it is satisfying to have that
competitive experience even if it isn't
a game that's like largely
uh i mean comparatively casual to other
pvp experiences but
i was on destiny 2 for a long time pvp
wise and
the the map
variation is is really
it really
gets to you after a while to the point
where when halo infinity came out i was
like oh my god thank god
thank god i have something else to play
that's a little bit more competitively
satisfying but
you know
it's just it i think the thing that's
strange to me is that they don't even
really have to prioritize pvp they just
need to take what's already been there
and put it back like i like i'm not a
look i'm not a game dev i'm not going to
pretend to know like how much work goes
into re-introducing
something back into a sandbox and and
maybe taking something from d1 putting
it into d2 but i mean the cosmodrome as
a destination is in there they brought
d1 mars back for an exotic quest like
surely there's a way to bring those d1
maps into d2 in a way that is
you know that doesn't break the game or
or the or in a way that the game can
handle and even just something simple
like hey bring the bring that suite of
maps back
and let us get on our sparrows in pvp
again
like i loved sniping people off of
sparrows in d1 that was so satisfying
yeah that goes back i mean that was part
of the plan with d1 was to have like a
halo type sandbox where there were
vehicles interplaying with uh combined
arms yeah like first first light was
that the lap the map on the moon
yeah there were a couple of them there
was a big mars map that had a tank on it
and stuff
they they uh they they turned away from
that real quick and and to be fair the
vehicles were not implemented well but i
have long held that that's when they
gave up on pvp not recently like when
they took away the week two they just
yeah when they took away the vehicles
like in that first year and said like oh
we're it wasn't that early i think maybe
they survived the first year doing that
because i remember that mars the big
mars map was added later but i remember
when that happened i was like yeah they
don't care about pvp because you don't
change your entire premise of your pvp
environment you know your pvp setup if
you're if you're not confident that it's
gonna work yeah i i i think a big a big
part of that was just how
quickly players began to like titan
skating in d1 was crazy and just the
fact that
i i'm always of the thought like in
vehicles like a vehicle should offer you
something that you can't get
on your own right it should be a risk
reward where like okay here's a vehicle
it's going to make me a bigger target
but it's going to allow me to traverse
the area faster or it's going to give me
more firepower than i otherwise would
have and when you're a flying wizard
with galahorn
a vehicle doesn't really offer you much
of anything
even in the realm of traversal i mean
you're [ __ ] you're flying yeah with a
homing rocket launcher that shoots other
homing rockets you know like it's it's i
could see why they pivoted away from
vehicles at in general
but at the same time
i do think at the very least being able
to summon a sparrow in pvp like on a big
map at the very least if you're not
going to put the pikes in there if
you're not going to put the tanks in
there at least let us do that because
that is
that's a way faster means of traversal
than than you can get on your own unless
you're really like unless you're a
beyond light year one
unless you're beyond like titan you know
where you could just like melee across
the map
you know us i was too believe me yeah
beautiful
are we still in everybody's existence
are you a titan or what do you play
me i'm uh i'm a ty in d1 i was a hunter
but i remember starting d2 and trying
hunter and i i felt like they were super
toned down and weak and
[ __ ] embarrassing i don't know like
there's and also just like i didn't like
the look of hunters in vanilla d2
you know like vanilla d2 they looked
like
warframe
like ninjas or something like they look
like really sleek and weird whereas in
d1 they were more uh they were more like
kind of space cowboy
there was like more
yeah there was like a weird like ninja
thing going on i was like ah
i'm gonna go with i'm gonna go with easy
on a ninja slanted but continue
no i feel you i'm not even a hunter
though
no i just i remember seeing the titan i
was like that looks like a spartan i'll
take it whatever yeah correct that's
what i did too i was like oh it's like
master chief let's get on that yeah
and i've just been sticking with titan
ever since uh just because i i i i go
uh it's titan for me then hunter than
warlock at the very end because i i
cannot stand oh i cannot stand warlocks
he's doing well with them
i cannot do it every time look look dude
every time every time i die in destiny
and i don't know what the [ __ ] happened
it's always it's always a warlock it's
it's never anyone else i swear to you
we're gonna go now all right so
the warlock is it the warlock jump
or what is it about the warlock that
just pisses you i need to know this
specific real quick it's the one hit
long range explosive melees and hey i
have a dawn blade now and now i'm flying
like i'm a [ __ ] uav i'm a goddamn
apache helicopter out of reach from
everybody who shoots homing
homing
uh the homing long distance sword
it's like all right let's calm
down for people who can't aim on their
own so they need yeah
[Laughter]
full responsibility for how ridiculous
we were in d1 literally breaking every
encounter yeah some figures were
definitely broken it was there was a
literally
do-over mechanic do over like you wanted
a warlock in the nightfall
yeah but everybody wiped and stuff like
that but i feel you on it we will
continue but we got we got some stuff to
talk about what's going on
i think we fixed everything because it's
stable now so
knock on wood hopefully you guys got
the the riffing going on but between
between these three i don't even need a
run of show i gave them one and it's
pretty much pointless so
i may as well just talk about destiny
what i think you guys were already into
anyway but my actual question to kind of
go through a little more of negative and
then positive was
what are your guys like as we've been
spent we're in week two you guys have
been spending a lot of hours with it in
these first couple of weeks what are
your
nitpicks for
kind of the seasonal progression or
witch queen or crafting
i know crafting i've got my own so it's
like i want to know what you guys
nitpicks are and i know we said like you
know obviously crucible's lacking we
beat that dead horse that's still there
gambit is
prime but still needs work and love and
finessing and massaging it's not done
um but one new map would be nice
yeah literally
anything or game mode please jesus but
yeah where are you guys at on weapon
crafting i am curious about that because
i've been working on that i know we've
got the patch coming next thursday which
we'll get to a little bit later but
where are you guys at for the experience
so far is it living up to do you see the
potential do you understand their
balancing do you hate what they've done
where you at chris you're first were you
out on crafting
yeah so crafting is is in a weird spot
for me
mainly because this is not necessarily
the avenue i go for in rpgs at all like
i i don't know like when i played skyrim
or any other number of rpgs
crap i'm not sitting there mixing
mixing weeds together and crafting like
i'm not doing that [ __ ] i'm finding [ __ ]
out in the world like it's the least
interesting part of any rpg to me like i
don't care
but because this is new to destiny i i i
figured okay i'm gonna go into this and
also the glaive is how you get
introduced to it so yeah okay i'm kind
of used to this now it's a little bit
overwhelming at first the new ui
the thing that i always tell people with
when who are like oh man i want to get
into destiny it's like be ready for
two million different types of menus
because there's always some weird
learning curve to every new thing that
they add that doesn't work like anything
in another
part of the game it's very bizarre
but
how it feels right now i think
i see where they're going with it i
think it's a solid
introduction to this system obviously we
only have
we have a very limited number of we
don't really have any any mementos yet
really to speak of it's a very limit i
think there's only a gambit one right
for right now correct so but i could see
how that once expanded on in the future
could be really cool i think
the idea of kind of working to achieve
your own perfect god role over a long
period of time is really cool although
by the time you're done getting all
those materials you've probably stumbled
across that god roll just by your chance
yeah that's kind of one thing that i
think is but the enhanced perks are
still there which is which is really
cool yeah
i think it's a good system i just think
uh
i think we're this is very clearly
version one you know we're very clearly
in the early stages and because the rest
of the game is so good
i'm kind of giving it a bit of a pass
for right now because i know it takes
bungie a little a little while to really
flesh out these systems into something
that's
really robust and where i mean look how
long it took for us to get void back
even just remotely back to the way it
was in d1
um hopefully we're going to be getting
that with arc and solar sooner than
later but
um
i think it's a solid foundation
i think the grind is a little bit
confusing given that again
you'll probably just end up with your
god roll by the time you're done
crafting your perfect weapon anyway
uh
but i think it's an interesting system i
i don't plan necessarily on engaging
with it too much
uh
but
it's
interesting i'm curious i'm more more
more than anything i'm just curious to
see where it ends up in like
a year you know like how how robust is
it going to be in a year
cog
um
kind of similar to chris i mean it's
i do feel i do see where they're going
with it my main thing points
pain points with it is the whole
beautiful element what is it a drawing
like
whatever it's not clearly stated like i
just feel like the ui is just weird as
far as how many like the fact that i got
to go to my weapon and then look at the
perks and then wait for it to load to
tell me which one because that is slow
right now
yeah the manuals are slow and then
like we talk about ui i just don't like
i understand they're trying to introduce
me to the system but it was like there
were times i'm trying to play the
campaign and the ui is overlaying and
yelling at me to do something i'm like
get off my screen like i'm trying to try
to play but now that i've gotten you
know a little bit more familiar with i'm
understanding the process you know
getting the patterns and and trying to
unlock that you know to me
it's it it does promote some d1
commitment where it's like okay you're
living with this gun you're being with
the gun you build it up but i feel like
those enhanced perks really need to hit
for that investment to me you know what
i'm saying so from what i hear because i
haven't made so much commitment a lot to
chris's point i've got a lot of god
rolls on on the way you know so it was
just like well why am i gonna commit
when i got the the what is it the void
scout that i like that has like
four times the charm and dragonfly or
the new perks turnabout or whatever it
is that i'm liking and i'm like well i
got what i want i don't need to go craft
and start from scratch with perks i
can't stand because let's be honest
those they they clearly value
the the very good perks at the end of
the tier you know so you literally got
to play with a worse version at its base
right and then keep trying to unlock
unlock a lot again i'm not like mad at
it again if you're i think it's going to
be a situation if you're unlucky with
rng
and you love an archetype right and you
commit
it can be a system that could work for
you but
as of right now there's really not many
that i felt the need to kind of commit
to that i haven't already just gotten in
the wild naturally so that's just where
i'm at but the glace shout out to the
glaive though glade was fire i i
completely didn't see that coming i
didn't because i was like all right he
looks a little why while he gonna do it
wonky and with the suppress which we'll
find out will not be ray but the
suppressed glaive and the other stuff
man yo the glaive is savage like um
yeah
it's really satisfying to that when you
get that three hit oh it's just it
there's something about it that is
really satisfying and and it reaffirms
what i had thought the whole time which
was
it's so weird that the sword is a
third-person weapon and i don't know why
they did that like yeah ever ever like
the second they introduced swords into
destiny i think destiny won right am i
yeah they were there yeah
yeah it was taken king you're right and
i remember when they added it it was
like oh six swords i love swords
obviously
the sword and halo is so so awesome and
then
you get it and it just pulls you out and
it's like why would
why would you pull me away from
a like a visceral you know what i mean
like it's such a it's a melee combat
personal experience yeah you want to be
you want to be up close and personal
when you're using a sword like it's i
don't know it's just very strange to me
that they that they changed that the one
but the fact that you have that again
i'm sorry oh were you gonna say i was
just gonna say the one thing i heard
actually about swords because when the
glaive was coming out they're like it is
our first first-person melee weapon for
destiny and the reason they said the
swords because i was wondering the same
thing i was like i would love to be
like you know i want to be first person
goes to sushi man i want that lethal
mode and i want to go in but they
basically stated that it's the way the
animations are done like if you picture
the vortex sword they would basically
break the camera if you were in first
person to do some of the animations that
they were going to do because i wondered
that forever too because it would be
very awesome to
just have the like the the titan sword
the big class one where it's just the
big overhead i want to see that one
first person but they said the way the
animations are done or the way they
chose to build them i guess is their
choice but yeah
that's that's kind of the thing could i
mean that's just
that's just a matter of time and work
it's like you could you could have done
it in a different way that wouldn't
break the animation but ultimately like
i get it like it's fine like the it's a
different weapon archetype but the fact
that we finally had that first person
melee weapon and it is as satisfying to
use as i thought it would be no
it's just it's really it's it's just a
nice new weapon archetype that again
something i haven't seen in any other
game i have not seen
i don't even know what a glaive was the
first time i even heard the word glitter
i was like what the [ __ ] what is it
glaive
doesn't even sound real and then you're
using it and this is this is it's it's
cool and i like that i like the
even the the low ammo cap and and just
like the way it fires like i was
expecting that to be a little bit wonky
and not fun
but it's actually super satisfying it's
it's it's just it's a good
weapon especially that's suppressed man
that saved my life yes yes um for sure
for sure man trout
they're taking it from you man taking
that surprise yeah i know yeah i figured
waves are probably gonna get uh nerfed
at least for this season this week at
least i don't know how they're gonna
deal with it but yeah it's a
suppressing glaive and then adding
another mod that lets you suppress last
longer like that was never gonna
yeah
they didn't let us have a fun for one
season champion yeah you thought they
let us rock out with the new toy for a
little bit you know i mean it only
affects pve so i i don't care but it's
uh yeah
i mean if you thought it wasn't going to
get nerfed this season i i think that
you're
yeah the weapon crafting we had a lot of
theories about it before it came out and
i think we were all correct about all of
them like it's kind of bizarre because
we saw all the problems on the wall we
were like well who's who wants to use a
worse weapon just so that they can get a
good one like by by that time you're
gonna have to have used it for like
hours
and that is exactly the case like you
have to do that there's also low-key
time gaining because of ascendant alloys
yeah it's not as bad but but like you
know i decided i wanted to upgrade my um
my enigma first and so now i'm just like
waiting on that osteo striga uh catalyst
because oh bro
i spent all of my ascendant switching
to get up yeah and raul rauhul decided
to he had supply chain issues
chip shortage
i mean
i get we're in a pandemic
so yeah there's you know there's that
and then and then the fact that it's
confusing is all
god damn i i i cannot six new currencies
and they're implemented in the
the worst possible way like my complaint
about last week about not being able to
see them i still think it's terrible i
mean you can see them in the in the
weapon
but only certain ones and you don't
really know which ones until you hover
over it and then even then it still
doesn't tell you how many you need to
upgrade it so it's kind of a pointless
number anyway all of that is completely
uh useless i just it frustrates me
the ecosystem destiny has always
frustrated me as i've talked about a
million times on the show and i think
it's it's now worse than it's ever been
and it's especially worse if you're a
new player if you're a good player
you're going to have
no idea no idea what's going on
like i i played with my girlfriend and
she's not used to destiny and she's
really into like hardcore rpg she plays
eso like
talk about currencies and she got to
destiny and she was like none of this
makes sense to me and i was like yep
that's correct you're you were right the
the names they chose chose for it too
the ruinous alloy versus that droid
neutral and that's just it's just a
bunch of it's just a bunch of words
it doesn't mean anything it's it's so
con
the current the sheer amount of
currencies has always has always been
like a sticking point with me like even
back in in d1 where they were just like
hey here's uh here's what ascendant
charts are supposed to do and and ah
they're strange different now
yeah strange coins i'm like
glass glimmer glimmer which in d1 was
useless yeah yeah oh my god the votes of
light
like it's just there's so
there's
this is one place this is one
tower this is one
society or country whatever the [ __ ] you
want to call the people why do they have
more types of currency than our real
world does
yeah it's insane
what's the exchange rate today they got
the board up there hold on i gotta wait
for page
the fact that there's characters that
you could go and do the exchange rate
with like we had to go to spider and
really yo what's the what's the price
going on spin metal today yeah
like it's literally a hustler when did i
get a job at wall street why am i
trading
in this in this fake universe it's crazy
to me and currency is an exchange the
destiny sec comes in
the point where i gave up is when they
introduced chocolate strange coins i was
like all right so now we have fake
edible currencies of an existing
currency that no longer matters in this
game and then what did they do they
reintroduced that currency so now
there's a game where you can have
chocolate strange coins
alongside real strange coins and i was
like all right none of this makes sense
i hate it all right that was that was
the breaking point for me but the other
thing that i think nobody's talked about
is
all of these ruinous and and uh neutral
and everything their icons are
completely
like
not unique at all and it it's that makes
it even worse there's not like color
coding you know like and usually in
weapon crafting you have like a a blue
color and a red color and a green color
and it's like very clear okay this is a
red weapon versus these are all
variations of orange
this one seems completely arbitrary it's
just like this one for this perk you
have to use this element and it's got
the almost identical symbol of the other
one that's out there and that part is
like even more mind-boggling it's like
you guys you guys couldn't spring for
like a different icon for for this
different
currency that you clearly put a lot of
thought into i mean you decided you
wanted to it to be in the game at some
point somebody was like yep we're green
lighting android alloy like
android energy you know whatever and
they
no icon
it just makes it all kind of blend
together in in a way that's like not
really helpful like i i could see how
like the onboarding for new players is
is just yeah i mean dude even as an
existing player who just takes breaks
occasionally to play other things
sometimes i come back and i'm like oh
there's a new oh there's a new
[ __ ]
toonie in the game or like oh hey a new
dollar is here and it's like what the f
i can't keep up with especially when
there's again there's everything kind of
looks the same like again like i
remember kind of uh when i was messing
around with the weapon crafting and
trying to somebody in my twitch chat had
to explain to me oh
the rui these these elements like refer
to the specific perks that you're trying
to work towards yeah guys and i was like
oh
that's not conveyed at all
man i appreciate a game that i
appreciate games that don't d that don't
tell you any like eldon ring doesn't
tell you a damn thing you know it just
sets you up but that's a different thing
it's a very very different game yeah
elden ring doesn't have a real economy
to take to take note of you know there's
runes i guess but that's it they have
one currency just runes yeah i think
that's that's like the way to do it is
just make because if you have all these
different currencies the problem is some
of them feel completely pointless and
runes you will never feel are pointless
because they're used for everything an
elton ring right like use them to buy
things and to level up and to
you know improve your weapons it's like
you always need them and this one it's
like
who who has ever needed glimmer in the
past you know five years of destiny like
it's crazy like why does that currency
even exist i don't understand it
it is very confusing i think i'm at my
glimmer cap
always most of the time yeah and it and
it's supposed to be the main currency
they use so like every guardian is rich
which means no one's rich like this is
like 1930s germany like our inflation is
through the roof
this is crazy we're like burning glimmer
just to keep ourselves warm it's crazy
i'm good
well for me i'm actually i was actually
wanting to go last to see if you guys
touched on you guys didn't actually take
either of my points which is even better
more things to complain about which is
great um
so first off currency caps they have got
to go oh my god i hate that we have so
you can have 10 ascendant alloy but so
those are kind of like golf balls but
they're basketballs i heard them called
now so we have two different sports
balls
we got ascendant alloys which don't drop
from rahul because as you said you got
supply chain issues your
ruinous and adroit and energetic and
mutable elements those cap at 250
and you notice that when you go to
finish the resonance
the deep site resonance process on a
weapon and it's like hey you want to do
this well you're near the cap and i'm
going
i knew it was coming
i finally saw it but of course you still
can take some neutral element because
you get that as well so you may as well
do that at the same time that's got an
arbit arbitrary cap of like what 8 500 i
think i saw tassie say so you got 250
here 8 400 here but we have 250 000
glimmer just like crapping it everywhere
and we got more of that that we know
what to do with
so we have
all these weird caps that make this
process even more frustrating already
it's like hey i got a red weapon to drop
cool okay my currency is currently full
now so i need to take that red weapon
even though i finished and it's got the
big explanation like use me i'm going to
put you in the vault and save you for
later
so now my vault space issues that were
because i wanted to keep some of these
god rules and have a little variety of
exotics and weapons and things now i'm
going to have just pages of red
exclamation points saving up currency
just in case i'm ready to craft that
next thing now there's going to be a
point where you've probably crafted
everything
but this gets me to the other part if
you ever want to switch perks on a
weapon that you've crafted and unlock
the perk you're like okay i'm gonna spin
this ascendant alloy on
the glaive and i want to unlock
the enhanced version of impulse
amplifier makes that projectile crazy
fast it's actually really good
very good yeah but maybe it's like i
know i'm gonna go into a crazy melee
fight maybe i want to switch and try
something else but i've paid the
currency over here so that stays right
no it doesn't i'm sorry what
i had to grind for the ascendant alloy i
spend it i get the enhanced perk but
it's not permanent that should be that
should be a very
that should be one of their main
priorities in my in my mind because if
you grind if you send an ally which is
already hard enough and then you have
the whole crafting table and then you if
you want to ever switch you cannot
switch back for free so the fact that we
have currency caps that you can't do and
then the fact that it costs every time
you switch
they made the system like i mean you
guys have all said it and chris said
it's like it's 1.0 i think is generous i
think this is like
beta phase like
1.8.8.9 we haven't quite got full
release yet need to iron out some more
kinks because
you guys have said already it's like i'm
spending time with this rocket launcher
that is
like it's it's not great i'm going
through i'm just using it as i'm going
through basic activities trying to level
it up so i can have all the perks but
then to experiment with i'm like okay so
i've got these red weapons i want to
have all of the resources here if i do
want to experiment but then if i do
experiment then i'm just burning through
resources for a non-permanent gain
so it's like
that's huge issues right now to me is
yeah it's like cool i'll get my glaive
where i want it but do i want to
experiment even though i put one i put
one enhanced straight on there
it's like you don't want to go through
the process of leveling up another one
like 16 so you can see all the perks or
20 so you get the little stat boost but
god forbid you change perks and you have
to spin that currency again as well and
you can't go back to the other one so no
those are my main issues right now i
mean everything you guys were saying
like the currencies being everything's
orange everything in regards to this is
a pizza slice of orange or something so
it's like that's every currency
and that's an annoying and that annoying
level line that doesn't
you know you know what i'm talking about
like when you're leveling up the weapon
it's just like this ugly orange line
that's just like stuck on your weapon
and just like ah yeah you can't master
work you can't get the border around oh
yeah yeah
it just bothers me it just bothers me
when i see it it shouldn't
but yeah that's like the fact that
another thing that bothers me is the
fact that because of the the red line
around the weapon if you'd say if it's a
deep sight weapon which by the way
terrible name one of the worst names
they've ever introduced deep sight what
the f what what is that like actually
anyway i that that bothers me that's
everything that's so that's so many
things to destiny i'm like why don't i
know but it's it's not even descriptive
of the thing that it deep sight oh yeah
totally i know what that means for sure
like yeah it doesn't make sense the fact
that you can't determine your loadout
really like if you're playing the game
well in your min maxing you're you
constantly are having like two to three
weapons equipped that like you don't
want to use but you need to so you can
grind through the level and then turn
them into materials and it's just like i
have used my ideal loadout for about a
combined total of 35 minutes this entire
expansion i'm just like i'm playing with
so many weapons i don't want to play
with that i am discovering like i was
like oh sidearms are pretty good again
you know you kind of make discoveries as
you please you guys i like that witch
queen sidearm though the little two shot
one just does not seriously connect one
oh i don't like it no i don't like it i
like the uh i like the witch queen
submachine gun that was the one yeah
that i do like this taste this one feels
great yeah yeah pretty good yeah this
one is good auto 720 is good yo but i
said to meet them seasons of the resin
weapons bro like everything everything
that's going on in the hell with the
flag with the silver with the blue flags
on them those weapons ridiculous that
auto rifle from rizzo oh sweet sour was
it see sorrow uh sweet sounds
yep
yo
very underrated that extra resilience
and the entire uh the timer in
conjunction with the artifact mod which
can extend it per kill which gives you
this extra resilience but i wanted to
real quick before you guys were gonna
move on um
my biggest pain point still i got i got
to go back at it it we i know we're
doing craft we're still talking crafting
but i it's the helmet mod bro the helmet
is just too many it's way over saturated
and and then they're really trying to
force
choice when they really need an extra
slot because speaking of land tank i
want to use that perk that it hit it
sends it then you have the the orb mobs
they're in there then you got the
scavengers are in there and it's like
really it's really now bothering me like
i'm just like i want to be able to have
a heavy scavenger in conjunction why is
the the extending of the factory or
foundry perks in that spot why can't it
be anywhere else like ah just certain
things that still bother me in reference
to that it's like once you get a high
enough level sadly i and this is the
thing i'm waiting to get in more of the
game is you have the artifice armor from
master grasp of avarice and if you can
get the helm you'll have that extra slot
for you know that one-off grinder we
still have the same amount of energy so
you have to spread it thinner which i
get
that's one piece of alleviation since i
think some of the
season pass perks are like worth one
energy but it still is annoying it's
like why can't that have 11 energy so i
can actually get that extra benefit and
still have my same build from what i had
before that's a way to use it but again
yeah it's like we're not
all of these systems are not quite there
so many and then when you start adding
up you're like okay now you've taken
away master working now my now i don't
have the satisfying yellow outline i
have a red outline just like screaming
at me the entire time then over here in
the helm there's not enough slots to use
all the mods that you've made that are
cool and i can't use them all and things
just start piling up and this is the
moments where when we spend 100 hours in
destiny in the first two weeks and
you're like oh i know it's a lot of time
but you start to see more and more
cracks piling up you're like yeah it's
still destiny it's like i love the
campaign but it's definitely still
destiny at times oh yeah
yeah yeah
if there's one more complaint i can add
before we move on to more positive stuff
that's why we're here it's the section
first this uh this release is probably
the most buggy i've i've seen from from
not just destiny but from a bungee game
it is
so buggy like you guys were talking
about the um
the new two truths and two lies uh
mission from sabbath in this week i have
not played that and because because the
uh the insights are broken for me
wow
the the the
markers are on the map but when i go to
them one of them is floating in the air
and there's no flag to do and the other
one it's like the the mission is like
cut off and the flag is missing and so i
can't activate either of these
missions and so i just i haven't gotten
the story this week and wow that's not
the only one i've run into man like i've
got i've had just like the weirdest crap
happen to me and and uh i've i've seen
it online too like a lot of people are
dealing with bugs uh from this release
and it's just
it's um very not usual and i'm guessing
some of it has to do with uh the fact
that they're working remote and the
whole you know covet and all that but uh
yeah it's really bothering me uh i need
to figure out a workaround for this i
haven't done any research because i've
just been busy this week but this
weekend i'm gonna be uh looking up i'm
sure there's other people who have this
problem and figured out a way to do the
insights but uh i've been able to do
either of them because of this wow
that's crazy they've done that yeah wow
yeah i i
i the only bugs that i've had so far
have been in in
specific boss encounters where like oh
hey that guy fell off the map or or
things things like that i haven't i've
luckily not had any like weird like
mission
uh mission specific like trigger uh bugs
but i have i have seen a couple of clips
out there that was like oh what the [ __ ]
yeah
it's just very unusual bungie's usually
so polished probably like more polished
than they need to be
because they delay things all the time
but yeah it's uh
it's not great and i feel like they need
to fix some of that stuff because it's
really bothering me like i i still don't
know what you guys are talking about
with the sabbath in progress i mean i
did all the seasonal stuff but none of
the none of the additional sabbath story
this week has has gotten to me yet it's
the ones inside the law sectors those
are the ones that are broken for you
yeah yeah okay yeah
i can't get them to activate i just go
in the lost sector and it just makes me
do the normal loss sector so damn that
sucks yeah
so what's going on in this game
besides everything we just talked about
yeah what's going on uh so we have a
slightly big event coming up uh i
thought it was hilarious because
you posted on they posted on twitter the
raidrace video it was about a minute
maybe a minute and five seconds long and
i saw you comment on it and i saw maddie
comment underneath yours and he's like
oh this is a big deal
it is hilarious listening to maddie is
completely and again not like this
destiny is the funny thing because we
were talking about it before we started
and destiny is like if you play destiny
you like you're deep into it we know
about these 50 currencies somehow we
understand this chaotic math and
all these things but for people who
don't play it they don't know when these
events happen and they're not but i was
like people who played mmos you can kind
of give them a reference point
but i don't even hear about like wow
raid races because i'm not into it as
much any like i'm not into it anymore
but it's like this is a special moment
we gonna maybe once a year because yeah
we're gonna get another raid back later
and it's kind of gonna be a race but
we've seen it before type thing
whichever one we get back
so these are these once a year moments
and this is once in
what is it now 15 months since it's been
so long since the launch it's been a
long time since our raid race and just
to see matty be like wow this is yeah
this is big and you were like yeah kind
of a big deal so yeah that's got a real
quick a quick story because we did we
recorded the fighting duke so i'm
telling him you know what's going on
and then
he's like what why what's this prep
stuff about and i'm like bro the ray
like you don't understand like he didn't
even understand how the mechanics of a
destiny raid really work so i had to
explain i'm like it's like six people
it's one of the most challenging
activities you know it's like you know
mechanics it's it's crazy so he's like
and as i can see i'm like selling him
he's like yo that actually sounds pretty
cool i said trust me whatever you do you
owe yourself just to play one destiny
raid because that was what kind of did
it for me i know chris mentioned this
earlier too like vlog for him right and
same thing you know for me i was just
like okay now see what it was so when it
was funny i just had that conversation
with him recording and then the the
trailer for the vowel disciple comes out
he's like oh okay this is a thing thing
so he's like getting into it he's all
right i may have to try one of them you
know in the future i'm like all right
you got to come out you got to commit to
like a full course he's gotta go to
destiny 101 destiny 212.
long before he enrolls in destiny like
313 for the raid he's got a ways to get
into that one it is
and that's the hard part the raid for
somebody who's already in it is always a
very special moment but for a new player
it's like is it worth the journey to get
able to do a raid
it's hard day one
not even day one i mean day one special
because it's blind but it's like even to
have somebody just experience a raid and
if you can kind of let them try and
figure it out it's just the journey of
everything we just got done talking
about what's the leveling process right
what's the cat what's wrong with
crafting what's all these thousand
currencies i can understand to get there
is a process but it's like the payoff is
really really worth it when you have the
moment of defeating the boss and then if
we get a cinematic afterwards and if
something cool happens to the world like
those events when you're in it
are those special special moments but
it's like to a new player for maddie
especially
i don't know if i don't know if he would
say same with you and like danganronpa
where he didn't want to start it i feel
like he's like he's got he's been far
enough away
but i don't know i want to do it listen
it's up to sony i'll tell you how we get
them that's how we get them chris
they have to they have to abolish the
dcv
the destiny content vault has to go sony
needs to drop it back and say okay if
it's vaulted
you can still play the red war campaign
the forsaken campaign all the way that's
all he wants he just wants to play
narratively you know and consecutively
into where it's at now so he has an idea
of what goes on and then he would give
it a shot but yeah that that i think is
it's going to be hard yeah because we
you know they need a bag for that but
enough about that let's talk about this
video i think they need a bag i think
part of the reason dcv exists is because
of the bloat of the game and the all the
playlists it was creating so yeah i
think that that makes it really hard to
come back because like you can't just
put like seasonal activities in there
like he would need that to catch up with
the story yeah it would also it would
also be like what like a 500 600
gigabyte oh yeah
like i under i understand why the dcv
exists i'm not the biggest fan of the
the implications of hey you bought
something and now you just don't have it
anymore that's in general just not
something i'm a huge fan of but at the
same time
i i remember when they got rid of uh you
know titan and all those uh all those
original planets and i remember thinking
thank god i'm so sick of seeing those
wasted
giant locations on my map that i'm never
going to go i'm not going to go to titan
you understand this is like
it's beyond light is like on the horizon
i'm going to go to titan no
i'm i'm glad in some capacity that
they're gone but
it is
it's hard to sell new players on it
because yeah that content is gone it
it's like it would be as if
somebody told you about
i don't know breaking bad during the
fourth season oh but by the way one
through three you can't watch them you
can't watch anybody sorry like you
missed it you're gonna have to like look
at like uh
my name is walter video
get into it
but
shout out to the bike though that was
shut up that was fun
who's been a savior of mine he's like
probably the main reason i got back into
it after taking such a long break
because have you seen no idea what was
going on i've seen a little bit of it
but like i'm not finished it's a time
commitment but it's very well done yeah
i've i mean i've seen a little bit of it
it's it's really well done but that uh i
don't know i think i think one of the
early i think maddie could would enjoy
vault
vog like i i think he would have a good
time yeah because that is that is just
such a
i mean it was my first one so like
obviously like i'm really like rose
tinted towards it and i really love it
and i just have like really really fond
memories of it especially because when
we
when me and my friends did it um it was
a bunch of people that i had met growing
halo and we had kind of drifted apart
and like and we came back together for
this this raid
and it was just like a really special
moment when none of us knew what the
[ __ ] was going on it was completely
blind in the gorgon maze and it's like
oh this is so
cool
and
that one
it's it's referred to as the best raid
and i think in large part there's a lot
there's a lot of reasons why
because it is so tightly constructed it
is so well done it's simple but it's
also it requires like
enough complexity in communication to
get everything done it's it's not that
it is a hard raid it's that it is a hard
raid
to to get everybody on the same
point on because and it's not like in
the same it's not in the same way that
uh leviathan was
hard because that was just kind of i
don't know in my opinion that was like
really annoying it was like trying to
guide somebody through
a [ __ ] ninja warrior
it's an obstacle clause it's an obstacle
course
making fun of you i didn't yeah i didn't
feel that first part of that raid but i
think uh i i think maddie would would
genuinely enjoy vaulted class because
the satisfaction of just working
together yes in that raid is really
really special and and you know there's
some other ones that i think
might be uh also pretty good to i think
last wishes
i was going to say if he could be
carrying the heart at the end of last
wish and be the one the last one
all right you just got it now the last
one you got to walk it from here to here
and that final march with the music and
everything yeah there there are a couple
moments as you said but it's like last
wish is also one of the most
ridiculously complicated it's like okay
here's the thing yeah yeah figure it out
just put them in front of the vault and
be like we're gonna be here until you
figure it out i'll see you next week
like you got to do research penumbra and
tumblr and all that crazy stuff i have a
i have a very limited experience with
ray i did i did vlog i did uh uh was the
crota's end yep
and i did
a little bit of last uh wrath of the
machine i did a little bit of uh i did
last wish i did a little bit of um
leviathan
and i i missed deep stone which i heard
was great oh so good deep sounds good
that's still in the game though right is
it yeah that's still there that i would
have tried
yeah the fact that that's even like an
open question
they have rotating weekly playlists for
raids you guys should do the same thing
for the dungeons
they're about to have four of them in
there well they do it for
prophecy pit of heresy shattered throne
and then now grasp
and that should like the legends play
should have your rotating dungeon in
there give me a reason to go back and
play pit of heresy it's still in the
game use it
you still make us pay for it don't use
it that's the worst part pinnacle one
pinnacle drop a week and you you
randomly select which raise slash
dungeon is the one that's up to bat that
yep makes sense to me i don't know
i'm with you bro
anyway but yeah so saturday 10 a.m
pacific basically an hour after
daily reset time wherever that
translates for you the raid race will
begin and you have 24 hours to try and
cross the finish line on contest mode
contest mode is going to be 15 30
anything over 15 30 is
not gonna count artifact does come into
play but i would recommend making sure
your weapons at a minimum are up there
but if you've been playing for a little
i'm like i'm just bumping at 15 51 15
52. like it's it was not hard to cross
the threshold of 1530 not at all
this is this has been one of the biggest
complaints for me is it takes so much to
get to the the raid climb and it's
stressful and i just like that you know
basically before the first week was even
over i was
at this level and i was kind of assuming
it was going to be 15.50 so all my
stuff's 15.50 and it was way easier and
it's not just that it's 15 30 starting
it's 15 30 for all encounters yeah
that's how they should do it man it
doesn't matter when contest mode isn't
is activated anyway like why why should
your light level matter since you're
capped anyway um so yeah they will get
likely increasingly difficult like the
delta between us and the encounters will
probably be more and more by the end
it's pretty we're probably going to be
fighting 1550 at least by the end if not
a smidge more just to make that contest
is going to feel it especially when we
get to the final because if we get to
that eight tracks moment
aatrex ruined me on deep stone crypt
that was
so many hours on that first date we
didn't finish it but that was there's
gonna be that moment where you're like
oh we just got checked
yeah oh yeah for sure and they've
learned a lesson you know i think the
last
you know since beyond like
doing it on a saturday you know picking
the right time giving you about more
than one week
from after the expansion launches so
that you have the more time a reasonable
light and i think they've seen the
benefit because i think remember it was
a deep stone the massive massive numbers
yeah massive numbers and ultimately
that's what you want because we all
agree you know it's a shame that the
early raids when you looked at the
percentages of actually completions and
people playing it you know it wasn't
high it was extremely low so to get them
to get that engagement and get more
people in is i thought was the right
call and i like how they handle it give
it about two weeks fifteen third that's
reasonable again i talked about the
legendary campaign as a great
springboard to get right into to pocket
if you do it if you if you up that
challenge you get rewarded it's good so
yeah they're in a good spot i'm i'm
ready man
are you going to be raiding chris
oh man i
i'm sure at some point i'm definitely
not going to be racing
because there's this i have no i have no
hope oh no i'm not racing i'm just
trying to stumble over the finish line
before 2402. that's all yeah yeah i i'm
going for world first
it'll be you and only like it's just
like no fire team he's gonna he's gonna
solo
yeah he brought back the the warlock
revive to be able to do it though yes
yeah yeah yeah
it's protestant all over again i think
uh
yeah i i do
i don't know raid the raids are hard for
me because it's really difficult to get
a group of adults
uh
that sits right there is all you have to
say is a group of adults
no just like
it really is just like that just hey do
you have an entire day potentially to
set aside for
uh what could potentially be hours and
hours of frustration and guiding
people you
otherwise care deeply for through a very
uh
a very frustrating encounter for several
hours that you might not be ready for
and it's it's not exactly the the
easiest thing to sell to people i have a
couple people that uh i know my my uh
one of my other one of my ex-roommates
was is super into it but it's really
just me him and and
we usually try and like find other
people but it's it's never as satisfying
as when you can get a group of of
six friends who like you don't have to
like
because there's always that moment where
you're like you got like two randoms and
you you don't know their voices and you
so you can't really like coordinate on a
dime in that same way so i typically
only raid when i can get those people
together where i can hear somebody
talking and i know exactly who they are
i know exactly who they play i don't
have to think about wait who is that you
know they know the terminology of the
game they know
you know where uh
you know
what classes to have and and it's a
it's a
i don't know it's a lot to get that
group of people together so maybe at
some point i do want to i do want to do
deep stone before i do this though nice
um because i i've just heard nothing but
good things about that
and uh
but after after i do deep stone i
definitely want to jump into this but it
won't be until
i i'll definitely be late to the party
on the raid because
there's elden ring her i got a lot of
[ __ ]
going on for sure i have nothing yeah
i'm i didn't start either of those on
account of obviously this but no it
pains me because yeah horizon looks
fantastic eldon ring is just i want to
get lost in elderly for literally 100
hours just stream it like every day that
i have off time between destiny and just
get lost and go wander into every nook
and cranny and i've heard it like people
have tripped over eight different random
mini bosses before they even got to the
first guy or they fought the crazy guy
and then yeah it sounds so much fun that
i want to get into
one of them i did want to ask you guys
real quick actually those who are
playing it because i have a friend who
is hearing it was kind of like skyrim
does it i guess more on the exploration
kind of unguided is it like
yeah elden ring isn't like skyrim i i i
think 100 hours isn't enough like i'm 20
hours into the game and i still haven't
got gone into the main castle that
basically gets you out of the tutorial
area oh wow like basically basically the
area i'm in is like white run you know
in witcher 3 where it's like before you
go to the main map and there's like this
a series of bosses that get you out of a
castle and then it opens up into the
real world and i've just been exploring
all the area before that and i'm like
i've killed maybe like 30 bosses and i'm
like level like 40 or something like
that and i just
they said go to the church and you'll
learn everything you need to go and i
went nope and i went the opposite way
and i've just been exploring all this
other stuff and
no i know nothing about the story i i
clearly i clearly am like missing
something i keep finding these things
that like refer to great runes and i'm
like i don't know what that is it
probably has something to do with the
main story and it's just it oh my god
man it's so fantastic i i i'm gonna
spend like 300 hours in this game i can
already tell because i'm gonna do
everything i need to do everything i
need to fight every stupid is awesome is
there a lot of cause for dark souls it's
like walk a hallway a little bit of
combat walk a hallway a little bit of
combat work through this area get to a
boss keep like it is all about the
combat do you feel
with elden ring there is still a large
amount of combat or is it just like
aimless wandering and then you get to it
is the combat still the relevant thing
you can choose to have combat in the
open world because you can just get on
your horse and run away from it like you
really can't it's kind of optional but
there is a lot of it in the open world
but it's more of these mini dungeons
that you go into where like they're
everywhere man like the opening area has
like 30 of these damn things and each of
them has a boss at the end and it's it's
it i don't know how they did it chris
like
is that sort of your experience as well
yeah no i tweeted earlier it's like this
is probably like the best open world
game that i've ever played and i really
don't know
i i don't know how they pulled this off
because it is so
i think
not to make this whole conversation
about eldon ring but i think you feel
like it's my fault
no no i i just do feel like they did
something really special here where they
just sort of they get out of your way
like they don't like
spam your map with map markers they
don't like give you a a million things
to do on a checklist they don't give you
like here's your side objectives and
here's your main objectives and then
they blend together because they're all
on the same list they just sort of tell
you
uh there's a castle to the north
and that's it they don't put it on your
map they don't do anything and they just
set you free in this world and the
combat is incredible like moving around
on your horse is incredible you got a
double jumping spirit horse that turns
on a dime it's like the best horseback
combat that i've ever had in anything
that i've ever experienced in any game
it's uh it's just deeply satisfying it's
really open the enemy varieties is
should put
the overwhelming majority of game
developers to shame in comparison it's
just it's it's
a remarkable game and the best way that
i can
kind of
pitch it as far as like a simplification
of it it's like it it feels like if
skyrim
and breath of the wild were shadow of
the colossus
there's like a breath pretty much and
like uh
and like an eeriness and an
atmosphere
and a respect of the players
intelligence
that
i i don't find in many open world games
if any and horizon
is a fantastic
example of a
it's like it is horizons for midwest is
a fantastic
modern
ubisoft style game it's like it's got
the map markers it's got the
annoying checklists and and despite all
that it it is a good game right but this
is next level [ __ ]
with alden ring it is and it's really
only that good because of the things
that it chooses not to do that other
games find
some weird
urge to do like spam you with all these
markers and spam you with all these
unnecessary cutscenes and dialogue it's
like i don't need all this just let me
get lost in the world like i used to get
lost in shadow of the colossus or zelda
or
[ __ ] any number of these old games
that understood
that the mystery was part of it
for sure and and it's actually it is a
stark
kind of you get whiplash going back and
forth between eldon ring and forbidden
west because forbidden west is the exact
opposite of elden ring when it comes to
hand holding they yeah you so much it's
it's like i think i can i think i can
glide to that ledge it's like yeah i
know i can't
she comments on everything like like i
don't think there's more than 15 seconds
where ailoy isn't saying something and
it's almost always like
hey
i found a new item i'll put it in my
stash they did patch the stash i heard
how much she talks but uh yeah the hand
holdiness
it is like
probably the worst i've ever seen in a
game and then you go and you play elden
ring and you're like oh thank god like
i'm so glad to be free of that that
prison that they put me in it's like
it's like being in school
now i really am debating on the order of
these two now the way you guys talk
about it more because
yeah it's like horizon is gonna have a
start to a finish it feels like elden
ring i'm just gonna
be lost for a while here's the thing i i
would i think horizon's still got a
really solid combat loop and it's got a
really solid story so like i think if
you
if you to like beeline that story i
think it's i think it's probably the
smart thing to do because the open world
is not going to be nearly as satisfying
as eldon rings it's not
it's pretty
but i agree yeah absolutely looks
gorgeous sorry my tangent everybody on
the podcast be like i'm just a destiny
podcast my fault i have questions about
eleanor since i haven't touched it yet
and these two i know have so i had to
ask so
um
[ __ ] you should play it stop being a
wimp please
witch queen which queen sorry i'm trying
to hear you
[Laughter]
sleep
i gotta discipline myself man nah man
i'm trying to i'm trying to live y'all
ain't trying to kill me
yeah we are
what's wrong with that man what's wrong
with that let's die together
uh yeah so
some of us will be playing chris will
wait a little bit us three will be
hopefully we can try and finish this
thing i know travis has definitely got
to try and do it for multiple reasons
i am doing it i'm getting it tomorrow
let me tell you i'm going to tomorrow i
got an a team i got d flawless we got
streamers on there we're we're getting
out
you got
i think i've done the past couple of day
one but obviously only one contest mode
but i beat these deep stone crypt the
first day so
yeah they did drop so we've got the new
raid belt which that's probably not
going to be between any of us unless
travis just goes off so okay he's got it
all right he got it
i want to see this on the podcast i'm
wearing it next episode you all get
ready
you know those things ship like sick the
bungee store ships like six months later
you're gonna have some time until you
get the new raid be out when it's
yeah
i'm going to pick it up in person i'm
driving up to seattle
it would definitely be faster than order
this shirt took me months
so slow i ordered my witch queen shirt
before launch like a couple weeks before
i
still don't have it yet yeah you might
get it before the final shape yeah
yo
yo
but if you guys are dealing with any
orders right now i've had issues with
different orders on lots of different
stuff so it's just a world right now uh
but the contest victory mode first 24
hours that's one of those things i wish
they would leave
as an option yeah they have the contest
emblem which does look very cool
everything with both the contest emblem
and then you've got the 24 the
completion emblem like the jackets the
first week we know about that thing but
both of these look like very dark and
darkness related kind of pink floyd
basically because everything goes from
like darkness and black to this like
prism of color
and we've also basically got the pin
that you guys can see and then kind of
like the
the seasonal pin seasonal icon and you
guys notice there's like a straight line
for the icon and then we have like one
two
three four
and then five so
somebody actually in the comments or
twitter or something basically stated
that
do you guys how many encounters do you
feel because somebody said this may
basically lead to the idea that we have
five encounters because there's five
branches on this little emblem
do you how how long do you guys think
the rate is going to be this is my lead
into this is why how many encounters
do you expect this whole thing to be
five encounters
five like chest level encounter type
things yeah they'll have like a weird
opening thing that's yeah like nothing
like like a weird
thing that doesn't doesn't really feel
like a full encounter and then they'll
have probably two boss fights and
another weird one
kind of in the middle of the raid and
then there'll be one big final boss
which i'm hoping will be witness related
or the new mob type or something like
we're not expecting that's going to be
like a game changer that's that's my
extremely high hopes that i'm sure will
be shattered instantly when i fight the
same scorn baron at the end of the fight
no names no name the score
yeah
[Laughter]
they keep reusing enemies that's
basically the short break from chris
like
the same yeah yeah yeah no i know maybe
we'll see omnigle again
who knows
we're gonna be fighting crota again it's
just the exact same fight
[Laughter]
general consensus usually about four to
five encounters
but the first really probably not being
any kind of just kind of get your feet
wet with the environment
i stumbled upon just kind of running
around patrols and i was like wait a
minute what's this area this looks
what's funny is i figured like that got
to be where the rain stopped because i'm
just like yeah yeah like who are these
two
hive you know guardians out here and
then i looked at the top and i'm like
yeah this this feels like an entrance to
a raid i'm very curious to see how they
my main thing is just narratively
how do they link you know the whole
thing as far as the witness and followed
the disciple being a disciple of the
witness so you know we i have my
theories there there's a lot going on
i'm i won't spoil i have some strong
theories there but if if that's the case
my only concern now is just like
it's that great pantheon of rage right
so
we we already established you know the
which queen campaign
is the goat campaign
but i want to know if in comparison now
to expansion versus expansion because a
lot of my taking king dudes are like yo
but that raid though can it can it truly
live up to king's fall can it truly
lives up to you know last wish all that
so
that's what i want to see and i want to
see
listen we know
it's going to be good
we know that right it just comes down to
how good
what is presented
i remember when you did last wish the
moment we saw a river like yo and ahman
kara yo like you there were moments
right when you see oryx over the board
remember e we we saw man
brian marcus they got the image of oryx
over the small little like there's
moments where you're like okay
will it have that moment that's my only
concern i think they could
if they do if they are ballsy and do
something special with maybe a reveal of
something or anybody race that we
haven't seen or something they they got
the potential because that's my only
thing i know it's going to be great i
just want to know where it goes so i'm
excited man i want to know what what's
the vow of disciple about what's going
on there yeah that's the big one for me
is the fact that
do we see something different part way
through
i mean we're going into the pyramid ship
so the architecture alone is going to be
awesome because i love
the architecture of the pyramid ships
when you go into the mission on europa
everybody's like oh we're just going to
go back into europa and do some
this place looks amazing i mean it was
just this turn from snow to
going to the pyramid every to every turn
that i go in i'm just like i love the
way they built just a little texture on
the walls the way it looks so for in an
alien completely different than
everything else the fact that we spend
the entire time in there the space
station on deep stone crypt still
amazing and there's a moment in deep
stone that's like okay so one do we get
a moment like and again i don't want
them to try and copy the deep stone
moments spoilers someone didn't do it i
know i haven't said the moment yet
but i haven't set the moment
no guys believe me like i've i i know
what you're talking about
doing the raid like i know what happens
it's just a matter of like i haven't
done it and i just haven't done it okay
there are there are moments
that happen in some of these races as
you said oryx
i think that's one of the biggest things
is
when guardians feel small when we as
players feel small in scale
uh it was like when i watched eternals
yes you can think about that movies you
want to know not everybody loves the
eternals but the way they
presented scale in that movie yeah
was one of those things i was like damn
okay that's actually huge and it's those
moments that they've done actually in
this as you said with the umkara with
oryx if they can have a scale moment
and a
vow of the disciple possible you know
other racial moment of destiny like to
bring in the witness and whatever's
gonna be there some connection there
where it's you know this like shadowy
figure that does when we watch the
cinematic he's not of form obviously
right if we get anything like that on
top of being in the pyramid ship yeah
it'll hit and if and then it i think
it's definitely got a chance then that's
and i don't know how the transition is
going to be like our score in the
defense and then we have this weird
transition is it just the one finale guy
so it's like i do expect a lot of finale
it's got to be finale it's got to be
finale yeah it's got it that's the big
group i'm thinking it might it might it
might only be one of the yeah
i agree
i agree the boss is something the boss
is something new yeah i'm with you
that's what i'm thinking it'll be it'll
then that'll be how they intro it to the
new race that's coming in lightfall
that's just my guess dude we're we're
we're living out and complete just ass
pull theory right oh yeah we have
speculation
we're deep we go with it
yeah it's so exciting first go no i'm
just it's it's just exciting to
because i i think a lot of the
excitement is just from how good the
campaign is you know just to and just to
hope like
so many of the raids have been just of
such high quality that to have another
high quality raid in tandem with the
first truly like genuinely great
campaign would just be like a really
great thing and i i don't know
i i it's scary at the same time because
before it was like oh the brain's
definitely gonna be better than the
story you know but now i'm like uh maybe
yeah
honestly i kind of i kind of prefer it
that way like if i had to pick i'd be
like make the campaign better because so
few people see the raid yeah
but let me ask y'all this though real
quick before i forget any chances
of a sabbath appearance based on what
has happened postcode campaign
i don't think so right now
no references no nothing references
maybe because you could have memories or
you know a voice over line or you know
voicemail that we've had those joking
things i don't see
much with relation to her i think this
is
i think this is intentionally
post-campaign cinematic we saw heading
that way
i think the sabbath in pieces are going
to develop over the course of the year
with memories and things like that
because again her ghost is still out
there and that type of stuff and like
we're not entirely sure
if she's dead if she's not we didn't
kill her in the throne world but that
type of thing but it's like
yeah i
i i'm hoping i guess i would say it is
progression
towards the witness darkness stuff
that's my hope at least
me too and i think everything points to
that i mean the swamp is think it's
called like the swamp of the witness or
the bog of the witness or something like
that so it's like very clearly the part
of her
mind that is dedicated to that time in
the witnesses service so i i would be
very surprised if it didn't go in that
direction we might find fight maybe an
illusion of sabbath dune or whatever
we've been fighting in the the seasonal
thing something like that but i i don't
expect that she'll be in it i will be
disappointed if there's not um a hive
guardians in it i was actually about to
ask you that yeah it's like because yeah
if it is darkness themed but we're
getting away from the hive i was
actually wondering if they're going to
implement them or how they would i i
would just prefer them to champions to
be honest
yeah at all i just i hate champions so
much they should take them out of the
game yeah i i'm not a i'm not big on
them either like i remember i thought
they were kind of needed in the
beginning it's like oh cool you kind of
have to you know spec your arms
accordingly but at the same time it's
like i have to play in a way that i
don't want to play just to play it you
know it's not necessarily
it's not that i don't think it's like a
valid challenge but at the same it's it
just takes a lot of the fun of
encounters when you have to oh i have to
use a scout rifle
uh which i don't like using or like or
you have to use a pulse rifle and it's
like damn the only pulse ruffle i have
is like
really not even close to my favorite gun
it's like sometimes you have that
situation where it's like god and
everybody's got to use the same [ __ ]
because
you know
the mods are only available for certain
things and just becomes a little
monotonous and boring and i i prefer a
gameplay-oriented challenge to a stat
oriented challenge i think
i think the uh i think the hive
guardians were just such a great breath
of fresh air and exactly what the
sandbox needed
to really like pull the gameplay forward
in a way that wasn't so
um
that wasn't so driven by these
background
background elements of the ui and
background elements of character
customization just having that challenge
and and just having that challenge in
addition to
the thought process of like okay these
guys can resurrect and they're strong
and they can one hit me
do i make a mad dash for him once i kill
him and deal with the mobs later or do i
clear out the mobs so that i have a
chance at really like
that that thought process is fun to have
in any game and to have that in destiny
finally is just really nice and the
champions just didn't do that it was
just a big tedious like uh i gotta yeah
yeah i gotta go into my menu to fight
this guy so i can equip the right yeah
that's like terrible uh yeah i also
think like it could be good as a game
mechanic like if you if you if you put
the
the the uh hive guardian somewhere where
it's like inconvenient or you have to
like create platforms to jump and get to
them then it becomes a puzzle of like
well not only do we have to kill this
thing but then we have to find a way to
get to it and we have to make sure we
have coverage on the map so that
somebody can crush the ghost in time and
it can be really good that way so i i
agree i just think champions would be a
big like okay this is a chore and the
hive guardians would be not only like a
cool new threat but also just
mechanically interesting scorn guardians
why not i was like if we all see a
scoring guardian i think we're all just
going to be like all right i have to
change my pants this is going to be a
problem so i think like
like every
it sounds ridiculous remember when the
the leak happened where we knew hive
guardians were coming like over a year
ago and at the time we all were like
that's insane like they are they would
they really put like a a hive with a
ghost and now we see it and we're like
oh yeah that seems normal so yeah
sure put scorn guardians in it nothing
will surprise you i would i would hope i
would hope for them to be present in the
raid in a in a decent capacity because
they are just such a fun enemy to fight
and in that darkness architecture that
dark city that you visit briefly one
missions is just like
so enticing it's like whoa
we're in castlevania all of a sudden and
it's awesome
it's so cool
very cool
i'm also really excited by i don't know
if you've seen this chris but all the
promotion for the raid has had this
rainbow beams of light like pink floyd
uh dark side of the moon album like uh
thing on it where oh i actually i
haven't seen a lot of it's all the
emblems yeah it's like it's like beams
of colored light going out of like a
pier out of a pyramid ship right and so
my current hope is that this raid is
going to be like legend of zelda light
temple where there's lots of beams of
light that have to kind of like be
redirected around and we're going to
have to be like solving puzzles as we
play that involve light and reflection
and that's just my hope based on on what
i've seen from the promotional material
but oh yeah it's very interesting i
definitely didn't expect rainbow color
schemes to be so present in the
promotion for the raid so that is
interesting yeah easy giving you some
images to check out yeah wow interesting
that is interesting mm-hmm yeah that's
man yeah that's kind of the weird nature
of going into the darkness going into
this black pyramid and then somehow they
have the as you said the prismatic the
split of like what a prism does to light
we get to see this full color wheel
scale of everything from the one beam of
light in the darkness it's this
it is there's got to be they're messing
with a whole bunch of thematic stuff
there which is always fun when they go
deep on it but
i will say between the two emblems the
24 hour one's cool but i like the normal
one more and i normally don't do that i
like the little pyramid over the light
versus the like circle wheel one
personally if i'm going to look at one
little icon in the corner of me
i like the 24 one which one you like
oh is the 24 one the top one 24 is the
top yeah
oh that's the top one i do i do like the
normal one then i like the lower one
sorry
my fault that was the opposite yeah
yeah i i'm okay with that though they
kind of have to give the one that's
around forever the cooler one and then
the people who get to flex
in my opinion the the legendary ones
have always been kind of ugly like i i
use the deep stone crypt one as a flex
because like oh i beat it
the entire time i was like god this
thing's ugly i don't want it
just because you know nobody else got it
yeah
i feel the same way
like with that yeah i feel the same way
i got the movie of the week once on
bungie so i i wear that emblem
it's so ugly but i have to rock it
because like nobody else has movie of
the week emblem like i gotta i gotta
flex this i just got a rare emblem
actually uh because the game to give
charity stream that i did
actually yeah so that was um
shout out to chat we raised like 3 800
bucks for the game to give charity all
goes to the bundy bungee foundation
which was going to all of their awesome
causes um but if you cross a certain
threshold just as like a fundraiser you
actually get a unique one for people who
break 2 500 bucks so i've got a very
rare emblem coming my way at some point
which is kind of cool
i will have to even if it looks just
even however it looks i'll have to put
that on the character too what if it's
just a jpeg of uh like promotional image
uh like a promotional art for like sweet
life of zack and cody from 2006. like
would you still rep that
dylan and cole sprouse as children just
like on your [ __ ]
sadly i would do that one because i'm a
huge friends fan you can give me a hard
time all you want but my wife and i are
both massive friends fans they had the
friends experience and we went to the
mall and can you imagine that above your
menu every time just friends with all
the doctors
my wife would be like what happened to
your gate
what happened weird crossover yeah weird
crossover big deal i did see one super
chat i wanted to call it out this is
just we were talking about this earlier
o.g tk cole which queen has a lot of
issues that people are overlooking right
now gambit pvp and economy we already
hammered that home believe me we agree
with you there are yeah we complained
about uh that was like the first
yeah shout hour
to og he must have just pulled up that's
the homie yeah we definitely went in on
all that for sure
yep um so yeah that is the big thing is
going to be this raid so we got scoring
possible everybody's thinking that four
to five encounter it's got to be a beefy
rate it can't be no raid layers no yeah
there's no shortness
yeah one attaching this to which queen
you've gotta be
protestant that's what we're doing yeah
don't no quote is no quote i always get
so much crap about curtis then it's fine
let's see let's see it's so good let's
look at it uh it is short right it's
great encounters there's multiple you
got the you got the lanterns
look it's a good it's it's a fun raid
but it's a short one it's yeah it's a
fun short raid yeah that's fair but it
was so sweet i would take that actually
i would i would be fine with the short
but fun raid but i think our
expectations are sky high because
they're introducing yeah witness this is
their chance to kind of build him up so
i think they have to
yeah so there's like five encounters
how long do you think it's going to take
the world's first team
oh man
that's a safe i feel like maybe 10 hours
to save i think uh
i've actually not really paid that much
attention to a lot of the previous work
i know i know
was it datto who came in second or
something second at 24 hours in two
minutes yeah the last wish was beaten at
like 23 hours but that's the longest
we've ever ever had a world's first last
yeah i i can't i can't imagine it's
going to be
over a day you know like but uh
i think i think i'm going to guess i'm
going to go ahead and say 15.
just to hedge some bands nice donkey
cog where are you at how long are
there's a chance the opposite will
happen it'll be over in six hours yeah
because i think deep stone crypt was
like that yeah yeah that's what i was
thinking too because i was totally
possible
just only because of the builds and how
creative people are
once they figure certain once once the
mechanics are filled out then they come
there's always that part there's a dps
check you know at some point
and what once god's figures out figured
out strats
and be like yo throw the suppressor on
weaken them here
we get extra 30 percent here and
they might figure out some bills i mean
i'll be in my mind i'm coming in there
with a couple things but
i'm gonna say
probably i'm gonna go like 10 10 or less
because i think
people are ready people are ready
they're specked out they're going hard
they are listen they're so ready when we
get to these patch notes
that bungie is like hey
we're disabling all these broken things
that you guys found in two weeks like
like all these broken strats that melt
bosses
and and do all types of crazy behaviors
we are disabling for one day so that
shows me like
oh the next day is just going to be
absolutely crazy yeah it's going to be
smashed the the the disciple go get that
work on sunday
like like the disciple is going to get
roughed
that's assuming the power level is still
1530. i think it might be 1550. you
think that they'll just let you
overpower and they'll let you do
artifact because everybody's over 1550
with artifact and all that anybody who's
been playing even like they usually
don't go crazy
usually about 20 below like you go look
up
i mean grant i think all the power
levels skewed now but previously
it's never quite it's not gonna be at
power cap i don't know if they've ever
done that now the encounters may
eventually get up there by the final one
like the disciple may be 15.50
but like the starting encounter is gonna
be like 15 30. people are gonna smash
most of that raid
24 hours and one minute later when
people log in the next day and be like
alright let's see how it is on day two
bam bam bam it's gonna get worked really
fast and it always does interesting yeah
i think i think you're probably right
about it maybe not being the full thing
but yeah i think you'll probably need to
be
1550 if you actually want the advantage
because otherwise you'll just be doing
the same encounters contest mode if
you're 15 30 and you're
below it yeah shout out real quick to
res in chat rest 73 first time catching
a live podcast love in the witch queen
love your podcast listen every week
thank you for the listens appreciate
that one thank you for the ten dollar
is that australian dollars eight dollars
i think this is australia yeah yeah yeah
shout out to the other side of the world
so
yeah in the future
yeah right now how's the raid look by
the way let us know if you got that
future
no doubt
but as we like lead into this thing is
there anything else for this week that
you guys are
trying to wrap up before
cogs got that exotic quest to do have
you guys done the and have you done the
exotic quest for the other two i know
cog hasn't yet
yeah i've done all of them okay
yeah i have not
[Music]
had
vox obscure is the one i'm talking about
at least mainly that's i got that one
right right i i did not do that one okay
that one i was doing
yeah it's fun like i remember starting
it and i i remember loading in i was
like oh this looks
familiar what is this yeah and then
and then i had that moment where you
were hacking the door and i was like oh
my god
this is
this is d this is d1 mars i wonder how
much of d1 mars is here and it's a lot
of it yeah a shocking amount of it and
uh that was just a really nice callback
and i know that's like not
new content exactly but it's been so
long since you've seen that version of
mars that it was like a nice change of
pace and i personally liked d1 mars way
way more than the vanilla d2 mars that
we got i don't know for sure something
really cool about seeing sunken
skyscrapers and descending into the sand
and mm-hmm
so goddamn cool i remember farming for
relic iron for
years
but i think uh but i think
yeah i wanna
do that that mission
at some point super super soon i think
it's probably gonna be the next thing i
chase because i feel like i've done
everything else i got that uh what is it
that um the exotic worm
oh parasite
that thing hits like a truck by the way
that that thing is crazy yeah
i think it was that is a really and
apparently that gun talks to you i
haven't had it talk to me yet
after the initial cutscene but uh but
i'm looking for you have to get kills
with it
yeah yeah yeah
i'm looking forward to to getting to
[ __ ] around with that gun a little
bit more maybe that'll help me on on vox
obscura but
so far i i have not done that one yet
yeah the biggest thing about i keep
getting trounced by that time limit
thing yeah the biggest thing for vox for
me when i tried it i was like oh i
opened it at like 15 21. like after i
finished the campaign here was this
thing i tried it i got worked for a bit
i went back at like 15 47
second time i beat it so i mean yeah
it's noticeably different at level so
that's the biggest thing i can say is
once you're at level
so i soloed it my second time so it was
it's it's pretty manageable at that
point i tried i tried at 1510 because i
was like maybe
i thought maybe i could run i thought
maybe i could run through [ __ ] and just
like be really patient
but uh
no
no especially since you're on a you're
on a timer on that one so yeah yeah
be patient i did not expect the timer
when i went in no i didn't expect it to
be that short and i'm going through it's
like stuff needs to die faster like
right now and yeah there was a couple of
kinks especially the tank part i feel
like the tank part is like a is like
it's a tight squeeze yeah i got pretty
close i'm a little bit behind in general
because i still got to get my galley uh
i've been i've been playing i've been
playing too many other things yeah just
try and then by the time i come back to
disney i'm like how do i get things i
i'm lost there's so many currencies i
don't know what the
i got [ __ ] yeah i got my vorpal weapon deadman's from
from
nice which uh nice which if if pvp was
fun i would be excited to
get in that grasp of avarice uh dungeon
and get that galley
my ex-roommate about it and he was like
oh yeah you should you should do that
and i was like can i do it solo he's
like yeah you should probably shouldn't
no yeah you're definitely not i've got
i've got a guide for you to do it solo
if you want but oh yeah e yeah he got
you here you guys maybe maybe yeah maybe
i'll do that it's a fun it's a fun
challenge solo because
it's it is one is it about patience
if you it's kind of like a dark souls
fight if you get greedy you'll probably
get caught out of position but if you're
patient with everything and don't force
it it's not too bad once you kind of get
a feel for it so yeah yeah it's a
function that's what i figure like i
just like those those those dungeons and
those and those
like i still think of like i think the
moment where like everything changed it
was like pressage when prestige came out
this is a turning point for sure as far
as like mission design in this game i'm
so sad that it's gone
i might not know such a good mission
you might not know this chris but
ibontis is kind of the biff of playing
destiny alone yes
my name is loner
i just got called out real hard there
thanks
uh he likes playing alone he's your core
audience right there yeah i do a lot of
solo stuff
i i do i i like playing alone too like
specifically like with the first time
you know like because i want to get i
want to take in as much as of the
environment as possible and it's kind of
hard when your friends are just laughing
at stupid [ __ ] like constantly it's fun
like after the first time to just kind
of grind stuff out to just it's it's a
great game for just hanging out and
maybe like even just listening to
podcasts and stuff but but uh that first
time i have to be completely
immersed completely engrossed because
it's just it's a beautiful [ __ ] game
like i i think the art design and
destiny in general is like super
underrated like like
just a gorgeous game to spend time in
i'm with you bro i'm witching them sky
boxes for me always gets me love those
mm-hmm all right final pieces
going going into the raid what is what
is the first things that you're going to
walk into the raid with
oh we talking them loadouts yeah the
last couple loadouts as we wrap up this
thing
with uh
i mean
all right yeah god that catalyst
is hell
i'm with you tribe the only reason why
i'm like
doing bungie that's what they gonna do
vintage bundy we know how dominant the
ad control co
is with that
they're gonna probably put
you know things we gotta shoot at a
distance you know what i'm saying like
so i'm like little squirrely rounds are
not gonna get that
you ranged it out right with the cat you
ranged it out with the catalyst oh i
don't have the catalyst because of the
alloy problem but oh yeah even even
dude i got through the entire campaign
on legendary i did it the second time
just to play it and it's like nasty dude
yeah that thing from pretty far away and
get killed yeah so no it's i'm not that
worried
that that's definitely on my own on high
on my list
i might go stasis eve
i might because i like the the warlocks
um the the arms that the double i could
do double turrets because my thing is
this with contest yeah that actually has
some some music they're gonna be lashing
us
oh yeah let's be honest right so my
thing is i want
ad control
while i figure things out
like don't be bombarding me stop freeze
and if i got to it i'm controlling if
it's like plates or whatever it is like
i feel like i can't me and shout out to
dj he is he in the chat we were talking
about it earlier and i was just like i
think we yeah stacey's like you already
know ftw salute so it's like i think i'm
going stacy because it's really and then
you know strong
ages
oh scepter is good because it got that
40 points
that's true so i probably for fun i'm
gonna go stasis first
but i already know there's gonna be a
point yo bro we need a well who got the
luna faction and now we're gonna have to
beat that just make sure if you're
running this thing
you'll be like i need one more warlock
and you get to babysit that well because
i'm running something different so make
sure you guys
you live well if you're in this team
you're i'm gonna have fun you live well
you do that if it's another if there's
another lock or another titan bubble i'm
the guy cool i ain't gonna do my
responsibility
like i want to just have phone but i'm
with you trav osteo is probably
right there neck and neck between me
ages and uh stasis build are all poison
out build and go crazy but um
i'm i'm excited what you going in there
you doing you got that hold on
try you know he going in there with this
a-list
celebrity team man
ain't you going in there
yeah yeah yeah tell them who you are
yeah you know what we talked about this
on a previous show oh yeah tell me a
raid group my raid group okay we've got
cool guy
great guy i had him on the show before
we gotta send it nomad
oh good guy coming on the show
he's all right heavy pete beast we got
true vanguard
what
this guy we got
kj hovey if you guys played d1 you
remember him being aj holy legend and
then jingleheimer as well he's the only
one i don't know specifically but i've
already a very good company so
honestly it's just gonna be a whole i'm
gonna sit back and i'm not gonna try and
run that [ __ ] very very worlds first-ish
we are
that is honestly one of the things i'm
very happy cool guys in the group is
because
cool guy when he was on uh firing range
he was like okay for your world's first
team set your alarm get up every hour
walk around stretch your legs make sure
you guys have your water eat healthy and
i'm like thank you i want a reasonable
human in this if we're in this thing for
the long haul i want a human i don't
want to be like i want to don't tell me
to crap in my chair get up get your
bathroom breaks go have your healthy
food prepped all that stuff okay
everybody alarm stretch your legs and
honestly if you're playing on pc you're
gonna need to reboot your game about
every four to five hours anyway because
that like memory leak with d2 is already
an issue so it's like use those times
take your breaks clean your head
so i was like i am so happy when i heard
him describe that because i was like
yeah i can do that
i don't need to be like all right i got
a catheter set up i'm good to go
it doesn't need to be that intense i
don't need the bag on the leg nothing
soda drink hat yeah yeah
you're uh you bought ibantas your uh
raid team sounds like the the uh the new
kind of touchy feely startup that's got
like unlimited vacation and they got nap
my raid group is like the old school
corporate like
you know whip it your back you know i
want you pulling levers all day in the
hot sun like that's my group it's a
whole bunch of like pvp mains who were
like if you're not willing to
ruin your marriage over this rage you're
not you weren't really hardcore enough
to play with that
what's this real life responsibility
stuff bro yeah for sure what's that
you can't hold it if you can't then you
can't hold me
your wife's giving birth you can always
just have another one there's never
going to be another
first person dude they make cameras for
a reason just record that you can watch
it later man yeah
right now we don't do the funny thing we
know dudes like that
for sure oh no there's a reason we're
joking is because that's half truth like
that is no joke that there's somebody
out there be like
uh my child just broke they're like dude
somebody else can figure that out like
there's just always something ridiculous
shout out to dj oros of course
hey guys thank you so much here a long
time fan just wanted to wish you and
have a great great day thank you sir
same to you good luck
hopefully you finish after me that's all
right
is he on your day one team he's supposed
to be but he has some responsibilities
that he has to take care of
wait what did this guy say he said
he said i don't know he's raiding he's
ready but i'm gonna blow him up but he
already he got people coming over he's
doing like a lan party he's got like it
he's doing like the race this on the
wrong day
no no but he's doing what he's doing
i actually did that i did wrath of the
machine yeah at my house with all six
people we're all in the same house with
our xboxes and it was amazing dj's got
like i swear to do it three i'm not
blowing up dj but i'm just saying yeah
like series x's and i'm like yeah your
bandwidth better be lit for all you like
like crazy
yeah like i hope so but he doing it
right but he was like damn i want the
raid with y'all because dj is fun
because he's the dude that you want to
have on your team because when you fail
the encounter he's the dude checking the
dps numbers at the end and see who's
noah he's like what's going on with your
damage
he's that dude so he'll get into it with
the dudes that argue about who's not
doing the most dps that's absolutely
always a good guy to have yes
that's
toxic yeah i don't know if it uh
you know it's but it's beautiful you
need to try hard dudes in that team
because you want to get the best dps
shout out to forte that's another one
you know save a voice sinister like iop
clan is hilarious with the dps kings
they they are funny when they're looking
at those deals
look at your damage look how much more
what are you using
i cannot optimize i control my loadout i
hate it it's like yo travis what's up
with your loadout and i'll be like bro
you died twice on that camera i was
alive the whole time so don't comment on
my loadout let's keep to yourself buddy
man mind your feelings
there you go
he was doing he was doing good until you
think he died twice he had to be a
warlock so you're disrespectful
sky right here
i'm jumped today there's all these
titans around here this is crazy it's
crazy
[Laughter]
you're surrounded bro surrounded three
times
i just jump them all well and just chill
out for a sec
oh my god
now i was like for me i gotta go void
just because of now like the void
overshield option that we've got void is
just strong and for me void 3.0
really makes me
not want to play the other classes
because there are exotics that can like
like the new exotic for titans that
literally just got nerfed yesterday
with the patch by the way the new fiery
helm that looks badass now it's like on
class
uh on class ability cool down only and
if you cast that then it goes away so
the healing spot doesn't just come
automatically so it's either going to
use your class item when you don't your
class ability your barricade when you
don't think it's going to you're like
all of a sudden oh that's there
or you're gonna go to use it and then
you can't have it so that one kind of
got nerfed but void just the overshield
you and anybody else can stand behind
your barricade you get a 15 second
overshield you can take it with you and
then come back and recharge that thing
on top of like bubbles or just hold up
your big shield and everybody shoots
through it just the power of that
overshield alone i think for titans is
going to be massive just for survival
oh yeah dude that's i've been rocking
shield titan for for way before even
void was was as good as it is now so
yeah it's it's been so nice to have is
that especially i've been because i've
been rocking a suppressor and grenades
with armamentarium and just having those
double having those double suppressors
is so especially when you got like high
high uh uh is it can i remember which
one the grenade thing is resilience or
intelligence
discipline
discipline yeah yeah when you got high
discipline with that thing it's like
insane it is so useful especially in
like high level encounters that's it
yeah that's been that's been my go-to
class and honestly dude uh tikkus uh
tikkus divination has been a godsend for
me
as far as like add clear i got i got
past in in specifically in the in the
legendary solo campaign i got past uh
that that lantern guy in the dark and uh
and even the final the final encounter
large part because i was just able to
scan the environment really quickly and
just fire arrows and blindingly into the
air and just chain together these
incredible like solar
chain reactions right that thing is is i
think a little bit underrated it doesn't
take an exotic slot and it is a bow so
it's like you know there's definitely
some give and take there but but they
hit harder so they got that primary bro
yeah
they did get that primary boost and just
banned unlimited even specifically with
those moths those like yes those times
to be able to just lock onto those
immediately with multiple words
you're just like
they're all gone and especially that's
so important when when you're at risk of
like having the ones that explode near
you it's uh
that's been my love
as far as like heavy and uh primary i'm
kind of bouncing around a bunch of
things right now i don't i don't have a
go-to uh
right now i've been messing around with
crait though
and that's that's a really auto yeah
yeah yeah
i'm liking i've always had a soft spot
for auto rifles though i don't know why
especially in destiny 1 where they had
that really like unique looking frame
that they never brought back um
but
i really want to test out this parasite
a little bit more i'm curious as to i'm
curious to see how it handles in
proper
like hard encounters because i didn't
get it until after i was done with the
legendary campaign i might just do the
legendary campaign again
just to see like how
just to see how it works but it hits
when you stack the damage on that thing
i went to
i was doing like legend law sectors or
something just deletes guys in one and
just bosses into one or two shots in
like last sectors it it hits like a
truck if you can get in position the
worm does not go that far though so
you're positioning it's gonna be a
little short shot
it's a short it's a short distance but
if you're uh if you're a hunter and you
got that reload on the on the on the
dodge that's like a pretty
it's a pretty pretty reliable hard hit
for
in a short period of time like a double
shot
no not bad shout out to forte real quick
no dj on the raid team i'm out dps is
king and i won't be the problem great
joey bounties have a great day same
thing
good luck
shout out to that's the homie here he's
rock you better be rocking with us for
saturday yeah dj he was in but he just
again he's got people literally visiting
his house he cannot ditch his people to
frame us so we're gonna do it but um
yeah man it's gonna be a phone we got
the squad sinister everybody ready man
we're ready addicts gonna be in there
have some fun saturday set aside a
couple hours trying to knock this thing
out man
i'll beat you there i'll be waiting at
the finish line when you're on the
finish line with the belt
he's just gonna be holding that drink
here's your water after you finish your
marathon i finished first
emoting or next to the treasure
this is a very exciting time we get it
every well it's been longer than a year
normally it's about a year that we get
these but it's a very exciting time um
but i want to say before anything else
as we wrap up chris thank you so much
for joining us this morning this has
been a hilarious show as i figured
between travis comedian we got chris the
comedian and then
trying to hold it down a little level
here we got a lot of entertainment on
the show this morning and i expected
nothing less so thank you for taking the
time out to join us this morning it's
been an absolute pleasure at this point
the floor is yours those to say
whatever else you want to wrap this show
up where they can find you if you got
another musical in the works if you guys
haven't listened to any of these guys
musicals please go
listen to a couple of these they are the
parody songs are great the research i
was cracking up so please go go watch
some of this man's youtube stuff it's
great
i appreciate that yeah i i don't plan on
doing that anymore just because it's
it's so like it's it's hard to uh
you can't do parody without just seeming
like a worse weird al so i think i'm
done
but i think uh you know i i'm working on
some uh fun stuff right now you can find
me over at uh youtube.com
c
chris raygun
and i've been streaming a lot on twitch
i stream every monday tuesday wednesday
and friday 1 30
p.m eastern standard time i'm going to
be streaming
later today as well i'm going to be
doing a lot of elden ring and a little
bit of destiny as well to take some
breaks
but uh you can find me over at
twitchtv.com chris raygun and uh that's
that's really that's it
now outside of a couple podcasts and
stuff
outside of the biggest playstation
podcast in the world
secret symbols
yeah
the biggest playstation specific one
yeah i think we're nice i think we're
i don't know the specific stats because
colin is the one who handles that and i
already got enough stats to [ __ ]
destiny destiny is all that's where all
my stat management goes like i'm sorry i
can't i can't have oh analytics
for my career
no thank you
i've gotta max my damage
uh but yeah sacred symbols snark tank
those are easy to find you can just
google those um
no direct link necessary but uh thanks
for having me on it was fun to talk
about destiny i don't really get to do
this a lot because
colin and destin and dustin don't
understand exactly they just don't they
just don't [ __ ] get it
it's the dirty secret and then you meet
a couple people at a party with the same
exact interest as you and you talk to
them for like two hours straight that's
what just happened
for sure
[Laughter]
travis when can we expect your review i
it one minute after the raid is uh raid
time is done sir right
basically i mean that's the goal i'm i'm
gonna i'm gonna beat the raid tomorrow
and then
just call in a shot right oh boy talking
and talking that too he's spicy i love
it i mean i have to i don't have a
choice it's do or die for me i got to do
whatever it takes so
um yeah on sunday i'm probably going to
be wrapping up the the last you know
ribbon on on my review um it also just
depends on how much end game stuff there
is after the raid's beaten because
remember last year yeah opening up a
bunch of extras a whole bunch of
activity and stuff so yeah we'll see how
crazy it ends up being um but
yeah i expect my review to be
posted in some form by tuesday at the
latest problem so uh yeah it'll be uh
it'll be done i'll give it a score i
don't know what my score is yet it's a
little too early to tell um but yeah i'm
uh
loving it and aside from that i've been
doing a whole bunch of other ign content
so you can find that on ign.com
and you can watch me on bitcast every
sunday morning where we talk about games
industry stuff if you care about that
follow me on twitter at ty guy travis
also follow this chris guy he seems
pretty cool
hangs out with one of my old uh heroes
from the games industry colin and uh and
uh has a good singing voice and all that
so you should follow me thank you
yeah how about you [ __ ] yo man first of
all shout out to the legendary ray gun
i'm so glad i was able to do this man
it's just the hair of talk destiny the
passion you know what i'm saying and
being a chance to work with them at lsm
is a pleasure so salute to you for
coming through yeah man the usual
podcast all sudden every sunday's the
lord's day we'll be back just the four
horsemen talking about we'll be drained
out from the rain see how tired we are
yeah start on sunday so luckily 11 a.m
start so that's good and then um yo
check out the friday duke this week
being maddie put it down man um god got
great interview with uh mark dara from
bioware i highly recommend my list
bro highly you get gems man mass effect
dragon age anthem bro you have been
proud of me
the anthem questions because as a
destiny fan i was like bro
you know i hit him with the what is it
what's this star wars you were supposed
to be the child you were the chosen one
yeah like i hit him with it bro like
what happened bro like
he was honest you know so give that a
shot i know what's on the page
five dollars y'all jumping i'm partying
on there i got you i got you
not you not you but i'm just saying to
other people like because like what is
it coming free like come on man but
anyway check that out it's up and
obviously we didn't do it um and yeah of
course that um he hates what i said but
last word man y'all y'all here now hit
the like button
yeah but um other than that make sure
y'all subscribing and and following us
putting out good content and loving what
we doing but uh e salute to you on that
track uh what is it the charity stream
thank you see what you're doing
what i'm saying it's big w man i like to
see you out there moving and shaking and
and doing stuff positive
there were two parts in there the uh we
started early with uh the advanced g dry
scoop that one was um that's a bit rough
but no i gotta come supporting the kind
of support my boy get to pass thank you
thank you yes yeah
that's right i still don't have mine
wait whatever
yeah you gotta send me an email because
if they get lost they're remaking them
because a couple cause it was right
around that snowstorm hit some the ups
facility by them basically got wrecked
or messed up so something happened so
yeah if yours didn't make it hit me up
because i got a couple that are getting
replaced
um okay
no like for me on that charity stream
that was really cool a lot of generosity
in there which was amazing a couple of
uh chat came through and literally like
hey i'm gonna match everything for the
next 45 minutes
um a lot of generosity in there which is
really really cool all going to a good
cause
but i have never really done the whole
hot sauce challenge situation
oh yeah mr condiment go ahead let me
hear this
chris you don't know me of the
background here i'm a picky eater so
they give me a hell of a hard time about
it in the first place so i have my food
thoughts
real quick real quick real quick
okay chris i'm sorry chris remember when
we went to the to the um restaurant
joint lsm we all link up
like picture that was my first
experience with e but at a destiny
convention and food came out and
condiments tried to be put on his food
and he's like removing it from the food
so i was just like what is going on so
did i add him like you don't put
condiments on nothing no ketchup no i'm
like he's like no i'm like what is wrong
with you
well i just had to say sorry he had to
get the proper context now you can
continue to start
yeah it's it's it's a real problem on
this podcast because
cog and i enjoy this thing called flavor
yes yes that's the thing is i like
concept flavor and seasoning yes
actually yes i don't know
anywho
i've i was trying i looked on amazon to
see what sauces i could get on short
notice and unfortunately one of them was
de bomb
so if you've ever watched the hot wings
oh my gosh i literally like never really
do hot sauce ever so i got
so i do so i got a spicy teriyaki with
habanero
and i was like okay so i tried the spicy
teriyaki with habanero you know actually
i liked teriyaki in the first place but
i was like how spicy is it gonna be with
the habanero i love teriyaki by the way
that's what yeah anyways see they don't
know everything they get some stuff
wrong
anyway
it's messy bro but the spicy terry
teriyaki with habaneros like i actually
liked it it had a little bit of heat but
the lingering heat was like that perfect
amount like if you get a spicy salsa at
a mexican restaurant it's just enough
that i'm like it's not on fire but i
know it's there i was like that was good
and then you put the bomb on no well no
and then that was the thing is like that
was like the charity threshold and i'm
like i actually like this i can't count
this as my milestone it's like because
it does so i was like all right i'm
gonna go get one
one more and i'm gonna put the bomb on
i literally died for 10 minutes on the
street
it was so
it just burned there was milk like the
milk would fade away then would come
right
back i have
that is and it doesn't even taste good
that's the other thing i've heard and i
knew it didn't it already doesn't taste
good it's just built to burn your face
off and it did so that was
yeah charity charity enjoyed that one
and then also at some point we are going
to get a full cheetah suit stream and
then a cooking stream so we get two
others you're you're out of your mind
man
who told you who told you to put the
bomb out i didn't tell you the bomb
what's insane i think look man i
i'm
i i will agree with you on on one thing
i'm not a ketchup person every other
sauce
i i like like i i dig like mayo i dig
hot sauce all that [ __ ] but like ketchup
for some reason just feels like
somebody's feels like like tomato syrup
and there's something like really
disgusting about it i got one thank you
i got one
yeah yeah but ketchup isn't my favorite
either but like sauce is this crazy to
me but mustard and like come on man
yeah not a fan of mustard dry sandwiches
your whole life just
drives just drops
just like you're just chewing on
sandpaper it's like that guy it's like
that that that great uh what is it that
that video of the guy like eating the
popeyes biscuit and he reaches for the
for the water and he dies
[Laughter]
it's going to be lit a gcx oh man yeah
so anyways yeah my stuff's
look me up everywhere i'll be streaming
as long as my eyeballs stay open from
tomorrow raid start i will be streaming
it so come hang out if you are avoiding
spoilers obviously go enjoy it yourself
but again thank you travis thank you cog
and especially thank you chris for
joining us a big fan of everything that
you do and the more i looked into you
for that intro the more i fell in love
um just yeah great content great
entertainment and
of course yeah go go check out sacred
symbols last and media it's literally
half of the show right now is last
handmade support half the show that we
got on here and you're in good hands
cause we got good company here and those
two are great right now it's the top of
the screen it's all last stand so
oh yeah
that's right
well as we wrap this one up chat you
guys have been on fire thank you guys
for the super chats and the support good
luck to everybody who is raiding
tomorrow including all of us in here
chris whenever you get to it should be a
fun experience
but to everybody here episode number 187
thank you guys so much it has been
the last word